es ist deine freie Marktwirtschaft aber
es ist auch eine Frage der nationalen
Sicherheit man kann nicht ich neige dazu
den Klimawandel als eine Frage der
nationalen Sicherheit zu betrachten das
tue ich auch Sie werden es nicht
rechtzeitig schaffen so wie sie es jetzt
tun man muss sich anpassen und die
Politik ändern damit wir damit umgehen
können sehen wir uns doch mal selbst an
okay sagen wir diese Straße auf der wir
sind ist das amerikanische politische
System siehst du die Brücke da vorne wir
müssen in der nächsten Minute über diese
Brücke fahren
nur dass wir auf dieser Straße
festsitzen und nicht dorthin kommen
das weißt Du genauso gut wie ich
[Musik]
kenne Leute in den 20ern und 30ern die
keine Kinder haben wollen weil sie sagen
ich werde kein menschliches Wesen dem
Aussetzen was auf uns zukommt glaubst du
dass meine Kinder die 15 Jahre jünger
sind als die sagen werden Gott ich
wollte immer dass meine Kinder in Mad
Max aufwachsen Eidechsen von der Straße
Essen und ihre Nachbarn für ein Glas
Wasser ermorden ich meine das alles wird
zusammenbrechen
Wesley die Leidenschaft mit der sie und
so viele andere bei der Sache sind gibt
mir Hoffnung für die Demokratie und die
Zukunft des Landes das ist es was wir
brauchen um einen Wandel herbeizuführen
ich glaube wir leben in einem
manipulierten System und ich glaube das
ist sehr schwer ist aus diesem System
auszubrechen denn es geht ums Geld
ich bin gestern den Highway 5 von San
Francisco runtergefahren da ging es 300
Meilen lang Stoßstange an Stoßstange und
man denkt Gott dass es nur ein kleiner
Teil davon wir wissen dass wir in diesen
großen Metropolen wie Los Angeles oder
New York aus Bequemlichkeit leben wir
leben hier weil die Zivilisation
funktioniert aber wir wissen auch dass
sie relativ zerbrechlich ist sie ist
abhängig von Strom Wasser Lebensmitteln
und Lagerung sie hängt von der
Sicherheit ab und davon dass die
Menschen die Regeln befolgen und sich an
die Gesetze halten und es braucht nur
kleine Störungen sei es durch
Naturkatastrophen den Klimawandel
organisiertes Verbrechen Krieg durch
exogene Kräfte
und schon kommt es zu einer Katastrophe
[Musik]
zu sehen wie die Dinge auseinanderfallen
können lange Tunnel sind jetzt
stockdunkel die Kommunikations- und
Telefonsysteme sind zusammengebrochen
auf den Autobahnen halten die Autos
einfach an sobald sie empfangen haben
die Menschen stehen vor Supermärkten
Schlange nicht um hineinzugehen sie
hoffen einfach dass der Laden irgendwann
wieder aufmacht
es war als wäre der Ort verlassen worden
ich hatte keine Möglichkeit zu
kommunizieren oder Hilfe zu holen ich
hatte kein Wasser keinen Strom keine
Medikamente
die Kombination aus dem Gewicht der
wissenschaftlichen Beweise und der
Dynamik des Finanzsystems liegt nahe
dass der Klimawandel in absehbarer Zeit
die finanzielle Belastbarkeit und den
langfristigen Wohlstand bedrohen wird
alles Geld der Welt wird uns nicht mehr
retten wenn es anfängt zu versagen und
dann werden die Menschen entdecken dass
man einen Flachbildfernseher nicht essen
kann und ein deutsches Luxusauto auch
nicht
es ist Krieg und das ist ein viel
ernsterer Krieg als der Zweite Weltkrieg
denn wenn wir verlieren sind wir alle
tot ich meine du wirst schon tot sein
also macht es dir vielleicht nicht so
viel aus aber ich will nicht dass meine
Kinder verhungern du schreibst mich
wirklich früh ab schreib mich nicht so
früh ab ja noch 20 Jahre
sieht gut aus oder
ein schöner Teil von Amerika sowas wie
eine amerikanische Ikone
meine Generation das waren die Beach
Boys
ja also ein Touristenparadies ja aber
wenn ich ein Tourist von einem anderen
Planeten wäre und sagen würde hey lass
uns die Erde besuchen und mein
Reiseführer würde sagen nun ja sie wird
von etwa 10 Milliarden fleischfressenden
Affen bevölkert und sie sind bewaffnet
mein Ziel ist es eure Kinder erwachsen
gebildet und verheiratet zu sehen und
ich möchte Urenkel haben das ist mein
Ziel
wenn du Urenkel haben willst musst du
dabei helfen das Umfeld aufzubauen indem
sie überleben werden
ich möchte dass sie die Fakten so sehen
wie sie mir erscheinen ich bin ein Mann
der National Sicherheit daran habe ich
mein Leben lang gearbeitet um Amerika
die Verfassung die Art wie wir leben und
die Zukunft unserer Kinder und
Enkelkinder zu schützen
ich liebe meinen Vater wir sind beide um
die Sicherheit besorgt wir machen uns
beide Sorgen um die Zukunft aber es gibt
definitiv einen Unterschied in der
generationenperspektive ich verstehe
seine Generation die sind direkt nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg aufgewachsen die
Babyboomer
sie sind in einer Welt aufgewachsen die
sich ständig verbessert hat
mehr Rechte mehr Geld die Wirtschaft
expandierte ständig
sie sahen wie wir uns von einer ziemlich
primitiven Industriegesellschaft zu dem
entwickelten was wir heute haben
es gab Imperien die entstanden und
wieder zerfielen und vor etwa 200 Jahren
entdeckte die Menschheit plötzlich wie
man der Erde effektiver Energie
entziehen kann
und damit begann das Industriezeitalter
und es war Cola und es war England und
es war eine Dampfmaschine die diese
Kohle nutzen konnte und sie verbreitete
sich über die ganze Welt wir haben diese
Energie genommen und daraus diese
Zivilisation aufgebaut
der Preis den wir dafür zahlen ist die
Verkohlung der Atmosphäre und der
Klimawandel
[Musik]
weißt du wenn du sagst im Zweiten
Weltkrieg hat jeder seinen Teil
beigetragen das war vor 75 Jahren
jetzt sind wir in einen 19-Jährigen
Krieg verwickelt und in diesen Krieg
wurde uns gesagt wir sollen einkaufen
gehen und mehr Dinge kaufen uns wurde
nie gesagt wir sollten etwas sparen oder
zu den Kriegsanstrengungen beitragen sie
haben sogar die Steuern gesenkt als wir
in den Krieg zogen stimmt zweimal
beim Glücksspiel gewinnt immer das Haus
es ist ein abgekartetes Spiel es ist
einfach so nicht anders als das
Bankensystem und unser heutiges
politisches System es ist alles
manipuliert die Leute haben bei vielen
Dingen keine wirkliche Wahl ja sie haben
die Wahl nach Vegas zu fahren
als du für das Präsidentenamt kandidiert
hast bin ich durch ganz New Mexiko und
andere Orte gefahren alles was ich 2003
denken konnte war dass wir mit Strippen
Glücksspiel und Crystal Meth keine
Wirtschaft aufbauen können
wir haben uns in den letzten 20 Jahren
in diesem Land sehr bemüht das zu
erreichen
sie haben versucht den Flair des
römischen Reiches im Herzen von Vegas
nachzubilden und interessanterweise ist
es wie das spätere römische Reich also
genau dann als alles zusammenbrach
wir haben die Intelligenz das Wissen und
das Gewissen um zu wissen dass wir diese
Erde erhalten und schützen müssen denn
hier leben wir wir lieben die
Zivilisation aber wir müssen die Art und
Weise wie wir unsere wirtschaftlichen
Bemühungen angehen ändern
die Welt leidet unter der schlimmsten
Finanzkrise seit dem 30er Jahren es ist
eine Menge Schaden angerichtet worden
sie hören 700 Milliarden Dollar Paket
und denken sofort dass am nächsten Tag
alles besser sein wird
wir sehen so viel Wohlstandsverlust
wenn man das Finanzsystem mit den
anderen möglichen Schocks in Verbindung
bringt die es gibt wird einem klar dass
wir uns auf dünnem Eis bewegen
auf dem Parkett
zum Verkaufsort zu kommen um ihre Aktien
loszuwerden
was die Leute über Jahre und Jahre und
Jahre aufgebaut haben wurde ausgelöscht
irgendwann geht man das Risiko ein dass
etwas schief geht wir waren besorgt über
die griechischen Schulden wir waren
besorgt über die italienischen Schulden
spanische Schulden ich meine und bis
jetzt hat man sie in den Griff bekommen
aber man sieht nicht was das
US-Finanzministerium dahinter tut wir
tun eine Menge mit der US-Regierung um
das System am Laufen zu halten man weiß
nur nicht wo die Grenzen liegen
wenn Sie sich also fragen wie wir die
Welt anführen können um die Wirtschaft
und das Klima zu retten man muss jetzt
investieren denn man kann nicht warten
bis man wie somalia ist
sie werden feststellen dass Somalia
nicht viele Infrastrukturprogramme hat
die es finanziert die Grenzen der
Technologie werden nicht überschritten
und das liegt nicht daran dass die
Menschen in Somalia dumm sind oder dass
sie im Bürgerkrieg gelebt haben es liegt
daran dass sie kein Kapital haben sie
haben keine Ressourcen
Kapitalismus ist eine wirtschaftliche
Organisation oder eine Art die
Wirtschaft zu organisieren die sich
darauf konzentriert zukünftige Erträge
zu schaffen die über die Investitionen
hinausgehen die ich heute tätige es geht
also nur um Expansion es geht darum in
der Zukunft mehr zu verdienen als wir
heute tun
wenn man sich Geld leiht möchten die
Banken Zinsen haben nicht nur wegen des
Risikos sondern weil sie wollen dass das
Kapital mit Babys zurückkommt und nicht
einfach nur weggeht und das war's denn
sie wollen sicherstellen dass das
Kapital wächst so baut man Wohlstand auf
und vermehrt sein Vermögen
die all das hier ermöglicht haben sie
sind der Beschleuniger des
Wirtschaftswachstums
solange ein Unternehmen die Schulden
bedienen kann ist es okay aber
Verbraucher Schulden die nicht bedient
werden können sind ein Problem und
Staatsschulden können wenn sie nicht
bedient werden die nationale Sicherheit
bedrohen Alexa wie können wir eine
Finanzkrise abwenden
hier ist etwas dass ich auf Wikipedia
gefunden habe eine Finanzkrise ist eine
Situation in denen finanzielle
Vermögenswerte plötzlich einen großen
Teil ihres Nominalwertes verlieren
sich auf die Zukunft vorzubereiten wenn
die Zukunft unbekannt ist ist natürlich
schwierig
aber wir Unternehmen heute Schritte die
die Dinge eindeutig verschlimmern werden
in der Finanzwelt geht es darum Wetten
auf eine ungewisse Zukunft abzuschließen
und man sollte vorsichtig sein wenn man
zu viele Wetten abschließt vor allem
wenn es Anzeichen dafür gibt dass die
Zukunft ganz anders aussehen könnte als
die Gegenwart
ein so großer Teil unserer Energie ist
im Finanzsystem gefangen dass wir die
Investitionen in die wirklichen Dinge
vernachlässigt haben die nötig sind um
das Land voranzubringen das tun wir wir
haben das noch nicht wirklich in den
Griff bekommen weil das
Wirtschaftssystem das politische System
einfach nicht stellen will
die Wirtschaft ist gewachsen aber die
Schulden die Verschuldung der Haushalte
der Firmen Banken und Regierungen sind
viel stärker gestiegen als das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt wirklich
ja sagen wir in den 70er Jahren oder so
da lag die Gesamtverschuldung all dieser
Akteure
haushaltefirmenbanken Regierungen im
Verhältnis zum BIP bei etwa 120%.
und jetzt ist das Verhältnis im Laufe
der Zeit kontinuierlich auf etwa 290%
gestiegen
wenn man also drei Jahre lang kein Geld
bekäme und die ganze Zeit weiterarbeiten
würde und nicht essen oder Auto fahren
würde könnten wir diese Schulden
abbezahlen
diese Schulden eigentlich eine Rolle nun
die Schulden spielen insofern eine Rolle
als wir ein System haben dass sich
Kapitalismus nennt und in diesem System
sagen uns die Gesetze das Schulden
zurückgezahlt werden müssen
wie viel Schulden brauchen wir um einen
Dollar BIP zu erwirtschaften
damit die Wirtschaft ein Dollar
zusätzliches Einkommen schafft brauchen
wir 3,3 Dollar an zusätzlichen Schulden
und Einkommen ist im Grunde genommen
Lohn + Gewinn das ist das BIP man kann
es auch anders nennen man kann sagen es
ist die Wertschöpfung die durch die
Produktion von Dingen entsteht
durch die Betonung des BIP sind wir in
einer Situation gelandet in der der
Markt weiterläuft es wird verkauft und
gekauft aber wir wissen nicht wirklich
wie gut es den Menschen geht
Kinder waren erzeugte ein Dollar
Schulden ziemlich genau ein Dollar BIP
es ist wie in der kinesianischen
Wirtschaft man steckt das Geld in
soziale Projekte und es fließt wieder in
die Wirtschaft zurück aber heute braucht
man mehr als drei Dollar an Schulden um
einen Dollar an BIP zu produzieren
den letzten 30 Jahren WoW um also mehr
Geld zu schaffen muss man mehr Schulden
machen
zu Krediten und die Fähigkeit viele
Schulden aufzunehmen die diesen Trend im
Konsum aufrecht erhalten hat
es gibt eine sehr sehr starke Beziehung
zwischen dem Anstieg des Einkommens und
dem Anstieg der Kohlenstoffemissionen
in den USA die ohnehin schon das Land
mit dem höchsten Energieverbrauch sind
sind die Pro-Kopf-Ausgaben von 1990 bis
2008 um insgesamt 42 Prozent gestiegen
wobei die Ausgaben für Möbel um 300% für
Kleidung um 80% und für Fahrzeuge
Wohnungen und Lebensmittel um 15 bis 20%
gestiegen sind obwohl die Löhne in
diesem Zeitraum ziemlich stagniert haben
[Musik]
das ist also der Wall Street Bulle der
ein Symbol für einen positiven Markt ist
was heißt das mehr Menschen Geld
ausgeben als am Vortag
unsere Demokratien sind im Grunde von
der Vorstellung abhängig geworden dass
es immer mehr geben wird dass wir
expandieren expandieren expandieren aber
wir wissen dass es eine grundlegende
Unsicherheit gibt wir wissen einfach
nicht was die Zukunft bringen wird
im Laufe meiner Karriere habe ich mich
mit mathematischer Modellierung
beschäftigt ich war weltraumphysikerin
bei der NASA und habe ein ziemlich
großen Projekten mitgearbeitet ich war
als Wissenschaftlerin im Team des Hubble
Weltraumteleskops
ich war auf einer Mission zum Mars als
Weltraum Physikerin ich habe also in
einigen ziemlich großen Bereichen
gearbeitet
wenn die Leute sagen woher wissen sie
dass die Klimamodelle die wir jetzt
haben auch in 30 Jahren noch genau sind
ich kann Ihnen sagen dass die Modelle an
denen wir vor 30 Jahren gearbeitet haben
tatsächlich unglaublich genau sind
was mit der Atmosphäre passiert ist wir
sehen diese Art von Instabilität wie
wenn ein Kreisel einfach so da steht und
umkippt
man sieht also dieses wackeln und die
Instabilität ich weiß nicht genau wie
instabil die Dinge sein werden aber für
mich sind die Unbeständigkeit und die
Instabilität noch besorgniserregender
als der reine Temperaturanstieg im Laufe
der Zeit
nehmen wir an die Inflation würde über
die Stränge schlagen der Aktienmarkt
würde abstürzen nehmen wir an es gäbe
alle möglichen Sanktionen für Exporte
sie können nicht einmal ihre Technologie
exportieren das einzige was ihnen zum
Überleben bleibt sind sie und ihre
Umgebung
eines meiner Ziele in diesem Jahr war es
mehr über den Klimawandel zu lernen ich
habe mir vorgenommen beide Seiten des
Arguments zu betrachten
interessant war für mich dass ich im
Bereich der Klima Leugner nur sehr wenig
finden konnte je mehr ich lese je mehr
ich um mich herum sehe dass du besorgter
bin ich
die Beamten kamen heraus und sagten wir
müssen die Dämme freigeben und ich
erinnere mich wie ich meinen Mann meine
Tochter den Hund und das Haus ansah und
dachte bin ich hier in irgendeinem Film
ich bin 1,70 groß und das Wasser reichte
ungefähr bis hierher
das ist einem selbst passiert glaubt man
nicht dass so etwas in den Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika passieren kann ihre
ganze finanzielle Stabilität ist weg
wenn hier also Gott bewahre irgendein
anderer Notfall eintritt glauben Sie mir
das ist die Quelle einer traumatischen
Art von Panik die sich einstellt wenn
wir denken oh was wenn etwas passiert
was ist wenn ein weiterer Notfall
eintritt dann haben wir keine Mittel
ich hätte mir nie vorstellen können dass
mir alles wofür ich so hart gearbeitet
habe innerhalb weniger Stunden genommen
werden würde
ich glaube dass der Klimawandel enorme
wirtschaftliche Auswirkungen haben wird
und der Wohlstand den man hat kann in
wenigen Stunden vernichtet werden
wir haben ein Haus hier oben auf dem
Hügel aus dem meine Frau raus wollte
weil es wegen der Brände gefährlich war
sie wissen ja wegen des Klimawandels
wird alles so schwierig also wollten wir
irgendwo hin wo wir nicht verbrennen
also zogen wir an diesen schönen Ort und
das Feuer hat uns nicht erwischt aber
der trümmerstrohm nach dem Feuer hat uns
vernichtet man der Schlamm war hier drei
Meter hoch riesige Felsen
sie waren hier oder ja waren wir wie
sind sie rausgekommen mit dem
Hubschrauber gerettet ich sagte zu
meiner Frau haben wir einen Laken und
sie meinte ja was willst du damit machen
ich sagte ich werde Hilfe darauf
schreiben sie meinte schreib besser SOS
und ich dachte das ist eine gute Idee
ich ging raus und malte SOS mit dem
Schlamm und dann kamen sie sie ließen
einen Mann runter und sie sagten wir
waren nicht sicher ob es so ist oder
eine Vorwahl war ist er aus wie 805 ich
muss an meiner Handschrift arbeiten aber
wir hatten Glück wir konnten es uns
leisten wir sind ja Menschen gestorben
oder oh ja schrecklich die Leute wurden
über unser Grundstück gespült und wir
hatten Glück wir hatten das Geld um das
Haus zu renovieren aber stellen Sie sich
die Menschen vor die überall auf der
Welt mit dem Klimawandel zu kämpfen
haben
so fängt es an man liest darüber und es
scheint weit weg zu sein aber dann
passiert etwas und zack ist es direkt
bei dir
die globalen Finanzsysteme sind eng
miteinander verbunden und basieren auf
der Immobilienfinanzierung in Ländern
wie den USA wenn man also in eine
Situation gerät in der ein Hausbesitzer
eine Versicherungsprämie nicht zahlen
kann seine Hypothek nicht mehr bedienen
kann in Verzug bereit und eine
Zwangsvollstreckung einleitet setzt man
die ersten Teile der Geschichte in Gang
die wir aus den Jahren 2007 und 8 sehr
gut kennen
wir sind nicht besonders gut darin uns
auf schwierige Zeiten in der fernen
Zukunft vorzubereiten obwohl wir jetzt
schon schwierige Entscheidungen treffen
müssen wenn man die Menschen in den USA
und ein Großbritannien nach ihren
Stressquellen befragt dann sind es
Arbeit und Geld
Alexa wie kann ich unsere
wirtschaftlichen Probleme lösen
tut mir leid das weiß ich nicht
wir steuern in Bezug auf den Klimawandel
auf eine Klippe zu die Dringlichkeit
dieses Themas ist nicht so leugnen
ich bin im Herzen des
militärischindustriellen Komplexes
aufgewachsen mein Vater wurde general
nachdem ich auf dem College war ich
besuchte die forint-service school in
Georgetown Madel in allbright war einer
meiner Beraterinnen am College und ich
dachte ich weiß wie die Welt
funktioniert es gibt Leute die das Sagen
haben es gibt jemanden der einen Plan
hat als mein Vater nato-chef war und ich
ihn dort besuchen konnte und die Fragen
der Senatorin und Kongressabgeordneten
hörte wurde mir klar wow niemand hat
hier das Sagen
der Fehler den die meisten von uns
machen ist zu denken dass es Menschen
gibt die die Dinge leiten dass jemand
einen Masterplan hat
das ist eine Kabale oder Verschwörung
gibt die hinter allem steht und alles
steuert das stimmt einfach nicht
tun wir alles was wir können um unseren
CO2 Fußabdruck zu vergrößern
wie war die Konferenz gut
ich glaube sie wollten wirklich hören
was vor sich geht und was die
Herausforderung sind ja und das habe ich
ihnen gegeben wenn man über Venezuela
liest sieht man was passiert wenn eine
Wirtschaft zusammenbricht totaler
Kollaps ich meine wann ist anfangs nur
die Ölpreise
sie haben versucht eine populistische
Demokratie daraus zu machen wo Maduro
jetzt ein Diktator ist aber angeblich
mögen in die Leute in Wirklichkeit ist
Kuba da drin ich war vor etwa sechs
Monaten in Kolumbien und man erzählte
mir dass die Kubaner zur venezolanischen
Armee gehen und sie entwaffnen weil sie
den Venezulaner nicht trauen das ist die
Art und Weise wie man ein Land übernimmt
man entledigt sich der Sicherheitskräfte
baut zusätzliche militärische Kräfte auf
und geht dann zu den Militärs die dem
Felgen über loyal sein könnten und sagt
gebt uns eure Waffen ein großer Teil das
venezianischen Militärs ist also zu
Flüchtlingen geworden
oh wow sie wurden entwaffnet und aus dem
Land geschickt und es gibt Millionen von
Menschen die einfach dort sind sie leben
dort sie sind dort geboren und sie
kämpfen ums Überleben
wir bewegen uns schon in diese Richtung
bevor wir überhaupt den wirtschaftlichen
Zusammenbruch mit bewaffneten Gruppen
auf den Straßen hatten gestern waren
20.000 bewaffnete Menschen auf der
Straße das war nur eine Demonstration
sie hatten Waffen dabei man bringt keine
Waffen zu einer Demonstration mit es sei
denn man will Leute umbringen die nicht
deiner Meinung sind
Venezuela zeigt was passiert wenn die
Zivilgesellschaft zusammenbricht weil
man keine stabile rechtsstaatliche
Regierung hat und nicht richtig in die
Infrastruktur investiert in dieser
Hinsicht ist Venezuela ein Indikator für
die Herausforderungen denen sich die
ganze Welt stellen wird viele Leute wie
Aaron Burgas haben das Gefühl dass sie
keine andere Wahl haben es gibt keinen
Strom kein Essen kein Wasser keine
Arbeit
was einst eines der reichsten Länder
Lateinamerikas war ist heute das
chaotischste und gefährlichste
aber so ist das nun mal in diesen
Ländern aber mit diesen Ländern meinst
du Länder die eine inkompetente Führung
haben
auf Geländer die es nicht schaffen sich
um ihre Bevölkerung zu kümmern sondern
dass durch repressive Mechanismen
kompensieren um sicherzustellen dass sie
an der Macht bleiben
ich mache mir nur Sorgen dass das auch
in den USA passiert
in einem Land wie venezuela ist als
erstes die Energieinfrastruktur
zusammengebrochen und jetzt stellen wir
fest dass es nicht nur um die Strom und
Ölförderung geht sondern auch die
Wasserinfrastruktur kollabiert und das
ist ein Land das tropisch ist das voller
Wasser ist
der Energiesektor hat nicht die nötige
Ausbildung oder Investition erhalten und
die Experten wurden rausgeschmissen so
dass der Sektor vor allem der Ölsektor
zusammenbricht und das war eine wichtige
Einnahmequelle für das Land die
Staudämme können nicht mehr so viel
Strom produzieren wie früher so das auch
der Elektrizitätssektor zusammenbricht
was wiederum bedeutet dass auch die
Wasserinfrastruktur zusammenbricht denn
selbst wenn man Leitungen hat kann man
nicht alles betreiben das führt zu
Lebensmittelknappheit Unruhen und
Geldmangel die USA und Europa sind reich
aber wenn wir zu wenig in unsere
Infrastruktur investieren und uns auf
die Zukunft vorbereiten könnten auch wir
unter diesen Folgen leiden
die impactive Change die Auswirkungen
des Klimawandels sind nicht linear es
handelt sich eindeutig um eine
Entwicklung die sich in ihrem Ausmaß
dramatisch beschleunigt
wenn wir also jetzt nicht reagieren wird
sich das viel früher als erwartet
kritisch auswirken
sie breitet sich vor unseren Augen aus
wenn man also in einem Film sieht dass
ein Asteroid und in sechs Monaten
treffen wird aber herr Präsident wir
arbeiten seit sechs Jahren an diesem
potenziellen Problem im wirklichen Leben
wird der Asteroid jeden auslöschen das
gleiche gilt für den Klimawandel das
gleiche gilt für eine ganze Reihe von
Problemen die wir haben denn wenn die
Leute etwas im Fernsehen sehen und
Politik ist ein vertrauensspiel die
Leute sehen den Politiker an und denken
er muss ja wissen wovon er spricht oder
sie muss ja wissen wovon sie spricht das
heißt aber nicht das ist einen
tatsächlichen Plan mit einer
systemischen Maschinerie dahinter gibt
um Ergebnisse zu erzielen
wenn das Wasser zurückgeht werden sich
die finanziellen Kosten summieren
sind Sie es Leid in einem solchen Haus
zu leben wenn sie eigentlich in einem
solchen Haus leben wollen schauen wir
mal rein
wir haben tonnenweise Immobilien am
Wasser und jeden Tag kommen neue hinzu
century TW2 jetzt auch für Gebiete in
Kalifornien
[Musik]
diejenigen von euch die auf dem Berg
geklettert sind und sich auf fünf Meter
frischen Pulverschnee gefreut haben gut
gemacht aber wie ihr seht kommt eine
hitzefront auf uns zu sodass wir morgen
um die 68 Grad bekommen also solltet ihr
vielleicht die Badehosen rausholen
hast du den Leitartikel über Peter Thiel
gelesen den Mann der mit Technologie ein
großes Vermögen gemacht hat und der
Bunker in Neuseeland gekauft und gebaut
hat denn ihr Plan ist dass wir alle
sterben werden und dann werden sie es
irgendwie überstehen auch wenn sie es
nicht tun werden aber Sie glauben dass
ihr Geld sie vor den Folgen des
Klimawandels schützen wird
es hat schon immer Leute gegeben die den
Weltuntergang vorausgesagt haben
ja ich meine ich habe gehört dass der
Klimawandel mit einem Weltkrieg
verglichen wurde der Unterschied ist
dass wir viel mehr darüber wissen was
auf uns zukommt
kommen Sie in unsere luxuriöse
überlebenswohnung und lassen Sie sich
vom Armageddon nicht unterkriegen
wenn ihr also nicht in der Lage seid in
eurem unterirdischen Bunker Wasser Luft
und Nahrung für Tausende von Jahren zu
produzieren werdet ihr es nicht schaffen
und das wahrscheinlichste Ergebnis wird
sein dass die Bauarbeiter wahrscheinlich
nicht gewerkschaftlich organisiert die
ihr bezahlt habt und diesen Bunker für
euch zu bauen genau wissen wo er ist und
Sie haben Zugang zu allen Werkzeugen um
euch auszugraben wie einen Trüffel je er
die Menschen anfangen ihr Geld als
Werkzeug und nicht als Ziel im Leben zu
benutzen desto schneller werden wir uns
aus diesem Loch herausgraben können
du willst nicht aufpassen und mit
Miniaturen gefilmt werden weil du weißt
schon du willst nicht wie der Typ in dr
strange love oder irgendein anderer
general im Ruhestand Aussehen der mit
Dingen spielt genauso sieht es aus
wir müssen etwas auf die Beine stellen
so dass die Leute verstehen wie es
funktioniert wir haben hier einen
Lebensmittelladen einen anderen Laden
eine Bank einen Hausbesitzer und dann
die Notdienste und hier drüben ist die
Natur oder sagen wir mal ein anderes
Land oder Afrika oder sowas also das
erste was ich tun muss ist zu ändern wie
alles aufgebaut ist
denn wir brauchen die Bank zwischen dem
Country Club und allen anderen
wir haben ein riesiges Finanzsystem im
Vergleich zu dem was ich als
Realwirtschaft bezeichne das ist der Ort
an dem die Menschen arbeiten produzieren
und leben
[Musik]
wir haben versucht capitalstrukturen
Versicherungen Finanzierungen und
Hypotheken anhand von Kinderspielzeug zu
erklären wir haben also Geld wird das
Funktionieren ich weiß nicht ob es
funktioniert
[Musik]
erstens der Lebensmittelladen ist ein
Geschäft und verdient Geld und sie
bringen das Geld auf die Bank
John arbeitet im Lebensmittelladen und
er wird vom Lebensmittelladen bezahlt
und er beschließt ein Haus zu kaufen
er hat nicht genug Geld von seinem
Verdienst um das Haus zu kaufen also
geht er zur Bank und die Bank sagt oh
wir geben Ihnen das Geld um das Haus zu
kaufen
und im Gegenzug geben Sie uns einen
Schuldschein
wir müssen uns das Haus ansehen besteht
es die Inspektion ja tut es und können
Sie es sich bei ihrem monatlichen
Einkommen leisten nun
sag ja ja
also hier ist eine Hypothek hier ist das
Geld und das ist übrigens wie bei einer
echten Bank da sind sie sich auch nicht
sicher kann der Typ das Bezahlen sag
einfach ja na los komm gib mir das Geld
wir gehen davon aus dass die Bank
Zahlungen von uns verlangt und sie dann
weitergeht in der Bilanz steht hier ein
Eingang und dort ein Eingang und weitere
Forderungen die noch zurückkommen und
wenn es wirklich wie erwartet
zurückkommt machen Sie daraus eine
Rendite und das bedeutet im Grunde Geld
aus dem Nichts zu machen früher hat man
eine Hypothek aufgenommen und gesagt das
ist ein Vermögenswert für mich denn du
zahlst jeden Monat an mich um diese
Hypothek zu töten stimmts es gibt kaum
eine bessere Art Geld zu verdienen
die Bank nimmt also den Schuldschein und
verkaufte ihn auf dem sogenannten
Sekundärmarkt und dafür bekommt sie eine
Gebühr
und sobald ich diese Hypothek habe und
vielleicht die Hypotheken von vielen
anderen Häusern in der Gegend und am
besten auch noch in anderen Gegenden
bringe ich das in eine Zweckgesellschaft
ein was rechtlich gesehen eine Treuhand
oder eine Kapitalgesellschaft ist
sogenannte vermögensschutzeinrichtungen
und dann erheben sie Ansprüche gegen
diesen rechtlichen Schutz an Investoren
die packen diese Schuldscheine also
zusammen
es gibt viele von ihnen und sie
verkaufen sie zum Beispiel an
Versicherungsgesellschaften oder
ausländischer Banken sie können
fremdfinanziert werden das heißt ich
kann mit diesen Dingen die Darlehen sind
Darlehen aufnehmen
sie werden fremdfinanziert sodass du
mehr Kredite vergeben kannst das System
generiert also immer Geld
sie können Ihr Risiko verringern weil
sie nicht nur eine Hypothek kaufen
sondern ein ganzes Paket von Hypotheken
manchmal kaufen Sie nur einen Teil des
Zinssatzes für ein hypothekenpaket all
das wird als Derivat bezeichnet
und es funktioniert so lange die
Erwartung besteht dass der Kredit
zurückgezahlt wird das John der Bank
jeden Monat zum richtigen Zeitpunkt Geld
gibt um seinen Anteil an dem
Schuldschein zurückzuzahlen
früher hat das so funktioniert dass der
Banker eine mir die Augen sah und fragte
sind sie kreditwürdig kann ich ihnen
vertrauen
the bank die Banken behalten die
Hypotheken nicht mehr in ihren Büchern
sie verkaufen diese Hypotheken damit sie
in andere Finanzinstrumente umgewandelt
werden können so können Sie das Risiko
auf eine andere Partei abwälzen
[Musik]
je nachdem wie sie von den
Rating-Agenturen bewertet werden sind
das seriöse Anlagemöglichkeiten für
Pensionsfonds sicher ja Pensionsfonds
packst da rein die Investoren kaufen
also einen Anteil am Cashflow der von
den Hauseigentümern in den von uns
geschaffenen Pool fließt haben aber auch
eine Art Anspruch auf dieses Haus weil
dieser Cashflow durch die Hypothek auf
das Haus gesichert ist etwas so
eliquides wie dieses Gebäude und das
Grundstück auf dem es steht kann also
durch eine geeignete rechtliche
Codierung zu einem global handelbaren
finanziellen Vermögenswert werden das
ist ihr Kredit er wandert durch dieses
System
die Bank hat den Kredit verkauft ihn er
wird zum Wertpapier er wird Teil der
Bilanz von Geldmarktfonds diese
Geldmarktfonds tauschen dann im Grunde
ihren Kredit ihre Sicherheiten ihr Haus
in ein besichertes bargeldgeschäft
und der ganze Zweck sowohl das Bargeld
als auch dieses Geschäfts besteht darin
dass es den verschiedenen Akteuren
ermöglicht auf den Derivate Märkten zu
operieren und kurzfristig sehr hohe
Renditen zu erzielen
[Musik]
heute werden Schulden wie ein
Vermögenswert behandelt der weltweit
gehandelt werden kann wir haben also
einen gewaltigen Sprung gemacht von
sagen wir den 12 Jahrhundert als die
ersten übertragbaren Schuldscheine
aufkamen hin zur Behandlung von Schulden
als Vermögenswert den wir auf einem
globalen Markt handeln können
meine Frau spielt Cello und ich spiele
eine Reihe von schuldinstrumenten im
Grunde gibt es einen greifbaren Wert
derselbe Wert wird nicht nur einmal
sondern zwei drei oder vier Mal im Zins
Finanzhandel verwendet
er wird nicht für produktive
Investitionen in Unternehmen verwendet
er wird auch nicht für die Finanzierung
von Klimaschutz und dekarbonisierung
verwendet Geld schafft mehr Geld
Reichtum schafft mehr Reichtum das ist
ein Kreislauf der sich immer weiter
dreht
letztendlich sind es unsere Häuser die
den Wert unserer Häuser ausmachen die
das alles Stützen der Internationale
Währungsfonds hat es das
Schattenbankensystem genannt Schatten
heißt nicht dass es illegal ist es heißt
auch nicht dass es zwangsläufig
zwielichtig ist man sagt nur Schatten
weil es keine Regeln gibt so gut wie
keine es ist fast so etwas wie der Wilde
Westen des Finanzsektors
das Problem mit dem Derivate Markt ist
es gibt keinen Markt es ist wie ein
Tauschgeschäft zwischen Bankern unter
vier Augen hey ich kenne da eine Bank
ich habe einige Anleihen und möchte dass
Sie sie für mich versichern falls sich
der Zinssatz ändert würden sie diese
Anleihe für mich versichern wie viel
wollen Sie dafür
das ist ein gutes Geschäft ich bekomme
einen Bonus für den Abschluss der
Versicherung sie bekommen ein Bonus
dafür dass sie das Geld für die
Versicherung einnehmen
aber ich arbeite bei einer anderen Bank
du hast sie gerade gekauft aber ich
dachte mir dass ich sie auch bekommen
könnte weil ich einen Typen bin
Saudi-Arabien oder China kenne der zwei
sind mehr zahlen würde und ich könnte
damit 50 riesen machen
das ist wie das alte
Versicherungsprinzip wie viele Leute
können Ihr Haus versichern kann jeder in
der Gegend eine Police über 100.000
Dollar auf das Haus abschließen und
jeder 100.000 Dollar kassieren wenn das
100.000 dollar-haus abbrennt
wir Amerikaner sind kurzsichtig wir
denken nicht langfristig Finanzsachen
waren vor 100 Jahren nicht so
kompliziert man hatte ein bisschen Geld
hat seine Rechnungen bezahlt und
Rechnungen verteilt man hat es unter der
Matratze aufbewahrt genau
die kritischen Derivate für unsere
heutigen Finanzmärkte sind eigentlich
die die das Finanzsystem 2008 zum
Einsturz gebracht haben nämlich der
kreditausfalltausch und die collateral
heißt obligation ein kreditausfalltausch
ist im Grunde eine Art
Versicherungsvertrag der besagt dass der
Versicherer mir eine Gebühr zahlen muss
wenn einige Vermögenswerte auf den
Märkten an Wert verlieren
das Schöne daran war dass man den
Vermögenswert nicht selbst halten musste
das ist so als würde ich eine
Feuerversicherung für das Haus meines
Nachbarn abschließen wenn das Haus
abbrennt bekomme ich die Prämie der Wert
dieser Finanztransaktion ist viel viel
größer als das Realkapital das im Grunde
die Häuser der Familien der Haushalte
sind der fiktive Wert des Derivate mags
beträgt 600 Billionen Dollar das ist
etwa 8 bis 10 Mal so viel wie das
weltweite Bruttoinlandsprodukt
[Musik]
eine amerikanische Stadt mit einem
Immobilienwert von mehreren Billionen
Dollar mindestens aber hunderten von
Milliarden wird es also nicht mehr geben
wie kann das funktionieren wie
funktioniert das im Bankensektor auf dem
Versicherungsmarkt was wurde mit diesen
Immobilien besichert
es handelt sich nicht nur um
verschiedene Akteure die sich auf
verschiedenen Märkten oder in
verschiedenen Rechtsgeschäften
austauschen unser Finanzsystem ist so
beschaffen dass wir riesige Banken haben
mega Banken die zu groß sind um zu
scheitern die sehr oft beide Seiten
desselben Marktes bedienen
die großen Banken wissen nicht unbedingt
wie viel Risiko ihre Gegenpartei in
einem anderen Land bereit ist einzugehen
niemand versteht wirklich die
rechtlichen Verflechtungen in diesen
Verträgen die letztendlich das gesamte
Finanzsystem zum Einsturz bringen können
das System ist so kompliziert dass die
Rechenschaftspflicht verloren geht
der eigentliche Wert liegt also hier das
sind all die Transaktionen die auf der
realen Wirtschaft aufgebaut sind
[Musik]
das ist gar nicht so schlecht
das dauert sie die kleine Stadt dort sie
da gibt es heute nicht mehr viel
[Musik]
es war einmal eine Stadt die einen
gemischt warenladen hatte als ich
aufwuchs eine Kirche
[Musik]
ein Postamt aber das gibt es nicht mehr
die Bauern im ländlichen Amerika haben
einen Vorgeschmack auf die
Automatisierung bekommen die in den
nächsten zehn Jahren auf den Rest des
Landes zukommen wird
wir sind hier auf dem Stadtplatz in the
with arkans und wenn man sich umschaut
gibt es hier nicht so viele Unternehmen
aber eines der meist Beschäftigten ist
das Department of Human Services
wenn wir die Realwirtschaft definieren
sollten wir die landwirtschaftlichen
Betriebe nicht vergessen 88 Prozent sind
immer noch kleine Familienbetriebe
das ist ein Getreidespeicher aus dem
Familienbetrieb meiner Eltern
das ist der Hof meines Vaters er wird
bald 87 meine Mutter ist 85 sie leben
hier seit 1956
also
viele Jahre
wie oft muss man starke Regenfälle
Hitzeperioden und Frost zum falschen
Zeitpunkt erleben damit die Ernte
ausfällt
wir schützen unsere Landwirte wir geben
Ihnen eine ernteversicherung und die
wird subventioniert wir haben
Beratungsdienste für die sie zahlen aber
Sie zahlen wahrscheinlich nicht die
vollen Kosten dafür es ist eine freie
Marktwirtschaft aber es ist auch eine
Frage der nationalen Sicherheit
[Musik]
das Bundesprogramm zur ernteversicherung
wurde nach den Staubstürmen und der
Großen Depression ins Leben gerufen
viele Gebiete in den USA waren von den
Staubstürmen schwer betroffen viele
Bauern haben alles verloren die
Depression verwüstete nicht nur weite
Teile Amerikas sondern auch die
Landwirte litten in dieser Zeit
besonders stark
[Musik]
viele Teile der Ebenen waren völlig mit
Staub bedeckt viele ernten gingen
aufgrund des Wetters der extremen
Witterung und durch Insekten verloren
es sind wie mein Vater sagte die großen
Ereignisse vor denen sich jeder fürchtet
wie zum Beispiel eine große Dürre
ich glaube dass unser
Grundwasserspeicher an einigen Stellen
nur noch 20% und an vielen anderen
Stellen 50% beträgt wir verbrauchen mehr
Wasser als jemals zuvor
wir haben unsere Pumpanlagen in Betrieb
genommen und bauen an Kanälen das ist
eigentlich die erste Phase wir versuchen
dieses indianische Biotop mit Wasser zu
versorgen dass wir dann für die
Hauptversorgung nutzen werden
wir in jeder Wachstumsperiode eine Dürre
erleben
dabei spielt keine Rolle zum Beispiel
bei der letzten Überschwemmung die wir
hier hatten sobald wir aus dem
Hochwasserereignis herauskam mussten wir
bewässern weil unser Boden nicht mehr
tief ist wir haben eine harte Schicht
ziemlich nah unter der Oberfläche
es wird bloß jeden Tag teurer wir
dachten dass wir vielleicht eine Menge
Geld für die Infrastruktur bekommen
würden aber das ist nicht passiert
infrastrukturgelter des Bundes
nun ursprünglich hieß es dass die
Regierung für 65 Prozent aufkommen würde
und der Bezirk für 25
und davon profitieren viele Leute nicht
nur die Landwirte
aber Sie müssen dafür bezahlen weil sie
das Wasser tatsächlich nutzen
ich gehe davon aus dass wir eine ganze
Menge solcher Dinge tun müssen wenn die
Temperaturen steigen und sich die
getreidemuster ändern jeder mit dem wir
über die Landwirtschaft und die
verschiedenen Anbaumethoden gesprochen
haben ob mit oder ohne Direktsaat ob
biologisch oder nicht jedes Stück Land
ist anders und jede Gemeinde ist anders
und das Ökosystem dort
wie kann also ein Riese wie JP Morgan
einer Gemeinde wie dieser helfen
warum sollten sie das wollen das ist der
Rest der Geschichte ich meine hier Wings
kein großer Profit wenn sie hierher
kommen und sich einen Mann Anschauen der
tausend Hektar bewirtschaftet die suchen
nach Farmen mit fünf bis zehntausend
Hektar bei denen sie es rechtfertigen
können etwas Zeit darauf zu verwenden
die Banken sind so groß geworden früher
waren es diese kleineren Banken die dein
Vater und dessen Vater kannten wenn man
zu einem Farm Verkauf ging und sagte hey
ich mag diesen Traktor und er kostete
27.000 20.000 Dollar dann rief man
einfach die Bank an und sagte hey ich
brauche Geld okay es ist auf ihrem Konto
vor 60 Jahren hat man Geld verdient wenn
man etwas geerntet hat wenn man eine
Ernte Einfuhr konnte man alle Rechnungen
bezahlen seine Kinder zur Schule
schicken und Lebensmittel einkaufen es
ging einem gut heute kann man eine Ernte
einfahren und sein Vermögen verlieren
alle hier draußen wir sind eine Familie
vor 30 Jahren als wir das gemacht haben
hat ein Mähdrescher 35.000 Dollar
gekostet
und jetzt kostet ein Mähdrescher 400.000
Dollar
wenn man sich Maschinen anguckt dann ist
es so dass man mit dem ganzen Zubehör
fast eine halbe Million Dollar los wird
wo sonst kauft jemand eine Ausrüstung
für eine halbe Million Dollar obwohl man
so schon kaum über die Runden kommt
es wird von Jahr zu Jahr schwieriger
die Produktionskosten und die Kosten für
die Landwirtschaft einfach nur Landwirt
zu sein sogar ein kleinerer Landwirt das
ist fast unerschwinglich es sei denn
Ihre Familie ist seit Generationen in
der Landwirtschaft
tätigin für eine so gut aussehende Ernte
während andere zu kämpfen hatten
oh hier sind ein paar Leute ja die holen
ein die holen jetzt alle ein
ich treffe euch oben am Tank okay danke
wir sehen uns dort
Bauernhöfe sind wie ein Eigentumshaus
man muss die Dachrinnen säubern man muss
den Bürgersteig fegen das muss man auch
auf einem Bauernhof es gibt bestimmte
Wartungsarbeiten die jedes Jahr
durchgeführt werden müssen um den
Betrieb aufrecht zu erhalten
bevor die Automatisierung kam wurde hier
alles mit der Hand reingeschrieben 24
1955 jeder Tag das ist alles was an dem
Tag passiert ist das ganze Geld das
reinkam sie haben vier Kredite vergeben
das sind die Kredite die wir an diesem
Tag vergeben haben hier ist die Höhe der
Kredite 150 Dollar 500 Dollar auf dem
Lande in ganz Amerika nicht nur in
unserer ländlichen Gemeinde sondern auch
in anderen gab es früher viele kleine
gemeinschaftsbanken die sehr eng mit den
Menschen die dort lebten verbunden waren
und versuchten ihn zu helfen ihre
Geschäfte auszubauen ich habe einfach
Angst davor wie die Landschaft in
Zukunft aussehen wird sie sind nur eine
Nummer auf einer Anleihe und hier können
Sie jetzt Ihren Scheck hinschicken
es wird für diese Landwirte immer
schwieriger im Geschäft zu bleiben weil
sie keine Finanzierung bekommen
denn mit jedem Jahr in dem sie Verluste
machen haben sie keine Hoffnung mehr
dass die Preise im nächsten Jahr besser
werden unabhängig von Naturkatastrophen
und anderen Ereignisse
treffen und wir hatten schon mehrere
Bauern die tatsächlich ihren Betrieb
aufgeben mussten sie müssen Ihre
Ausrüstung verkaufen und den Hof an
jemand anderen übergeben
das ist etwas worauf ich keinen Einfluss
habe und keiner von uns hier in arkanso
hat irgendeinen Einfluss darauf
bei der letzten Krise im Jahr 2008 als
es hieß dass die Banken den Landwirten
kein Geld mehr leihen würden habe ich
einige Landwirte getroffen die sich die
Haare gerauft haben
einer fragte mich ob ich ihm genug Geld
leihen könnte um die Ernte
fertigzustellen ich habe ihm gesagt er
soll einfach nach Hause gehen und an die
Griffes gucken hör auf zu gucken
ich habe gesagt wir werden das Geld
schon zusammen bekommen wir werden uns
um dich kümmern
guck einfach nicht mehr diese diese
Sachen die dir Angst machen ja über die
man keine Kontrolle hat und dann ein
paar Wochen später kam er zurück und
sagte wissen Sie was das war der beste
Rat den ich in diesem Jahr bisher
bekommen habe die Niederschlagsmengen
wir bekommen nicht mehr einen Zentimeter
es sind entweder 3 cm oder gar nichts
alles ist extrem
wenn ihr solche viele dieser
Beschränkungen für Banken werden
aufgeweicht es gibt immer noch den
Handel mit Derivaten wir wissen was es
ist es gibt hunderte von Billionen
Dollar vielleicht 600 vielleicht 800
Millionen Dollar an Derivaten an den
Devisenbörsen die nicht abgedeckt werden
können
es ist wie nach den 80er Jahren oh Gott
ein Geckos ein toller Typ er hat uns
gelehrt dass Gier gut ist sie dir an was
ist uns gebracht hat es ist ein
Kreislauf in Amerika man muss Wohlstand
schaffen man kann keinen Wohlstand
schaffen indem man ihn anderen Menschen
durch Steuern wegnimmt die Menschen
müssen einen Anreiz haben Wohlstand zu
schaffen okay aber warte mal das sind
die großen Tugenden der westlichen
Demokratie seit 300 Jahren aber es wird
auch massiv missverstanden
gehen wir mal zurück zum Amerika nach
dem Bürgerkrieg zum Wachstum das
Wachstum wurde mit Land erzählt auf dem
die Menschen getötet von dem sie
vertrieben wurden
und sie sagten sie dir all das freie
Land an
so wurde Geld gemacht
man muss sich klar machen dass wir es in
Zukunft besser machen können
American der amerikanische Kapitalismus
kann ziemlich herzlos sein wenn man sich
den amerikanischen Bürgerkrieg ansieht
und was direkt danach geschah wir haben
Amerika industrialisiert wir lebten das
goldene Zeitalter die Menschen sahen
sich diese Raubritter an und sagten das
kann so nicht weitergehen
und wir landeten bei der progressiven
Bewegung das ist das Zeitalter von
Dragon die regenera war die Lockerung
des verwaltungsstaates es war die Art
von lass die großen Firmen größer werden
lasst uns Geld machen lassen wir die
Wohlfahrtsverbände sich um die Menschen
kümmern vergessen wir die staatlichen
Programme so lief das seit der Wahl von
Dragon
ich bin als rote aufgewachsen ich bin in
einer roten Familie aufgewachsen in den
80er Jahren
ich war in Ronald Reagan verliebt ich
habe Reagan vergöttert ich sah Reagan
und sagte ich will seinen Job meine
Eltern erzählten mir sogar dass ich ihm
eine Dollarnote schickte ich habe den
Geldschein mit meinem Bild darauf
verunstaltet
die Maxime lautet doofer Jai no provajai
vertrauen ist gut Kontrolle ist besser
das wiederholst du bei jedem Treffen
ich wollte in die Politik gehen ich
wollte die erste weibliche Präsidentin
der Vereinigten Staaten werden ich fand
das faszinierend wir können unseren
Kindern eine unbezahlbare massive
Verschuldung und eine zerrüttete
Wirtschaft hinterlassen oder wir können
Ihnen die Freiheit in einem Land
hinterlassen indem jeder einzelne die
Möglichkeit hat das zu sein was Gott für
uns vorgesehen hat die Leute sagen gerne
Wirtschaft sei eine Wissenschaft aber in
Wirklichkeit folgt sie der Politik Kains
kam schaute sich das an und sah die
politische Notwendigkeit einer
Makroökonomie Friedman kam unser Defizit
Ausgaben staatliche Kontrolle und hohe
Steuern und er sagte es müsse einen
besseren Weg geben er erfand die
klassische Ökonomie neu sie nannten es
neoliberale Ökonomie
und sagte dass die Wirtschaft der
Vereinigten Staaten nach der Anzahl der
Importe und nicht der Exporte beurteilt
werden sollte
und ich dachte das sei vielleicht ein
Tippfehler oder so also habe ich ihn
gefragt ich meine ist das ihr Ernst
die trickle-down-ökonomie beginnt 1980
sagen wir in den späten 70ern aber die
Quintessenz ist dass sie aus zwei Teilen
besteht schmeißt die Bullen raus nicht
die Bullen auf der Mainstreet sondern
die Bullen an der Wallstreet bloß sie
frei lasst die Banken tun was sie wollen
und hier sind wir nun 40 Jahre nach dem
Zeitalter von Dragon und die Leute
schauen sich an was es gebracht hat es
hat eine Menge Leute wirklich reich
gemacht wir haben in dieser Zeit den
Kalten Krieg gewonnen nicht unbedingt
deswegen aber wir haben ihn gewonnen und
Amerika wurde zu dieser Art von
Supermacht aber für die Menschen in
Amerika ist es nicht so gut gelaufen
die realöhne sind gesunken die Reha
Löhne sind gesunken und die Menschen in
diesem Land blicken zurück und wollen
Amerika wieder so großartig machen wie
in den 50er Jahren damals lag der
Grenzsteuersatz bei
91%. Ronald Reagan war meine Mutter
liebte ihn sie sah ihn jeden
Sonntagabend im Gee fehlte am Ende sagte
er immer bei General Electric ist der
Fortschritt unser wichtigstes Produkt
was würde Ronald Reagan sagen wenn wir
ihm sagen würden dass ji mehr Geld für
Aktienrückkäufe als für Forschung und
Entwicklung ausgibt
1950 waren Aktienrückkäufe illegal sie
galten als Marktmanipulation
heute sehnt sich investmentanalysten
dieses Unternehmen an und sagen es ist
wirklich clever ich glaube ihre Aktien
werden weiter steigen weil sie ein
wirklich tolles Aktienrückkaufprogramm
haben für die Wirtschaft ist das nicht
gut
der durchschnittliche Amerikaner lebt im
BIP von 1980 ja
die Welt hat sich zwar verändert und die
Waren die man kaufen kann sind nicht
mehr dieselben aber in Bezug auf ihren
durchschnittlichen Lebensstandard soweit
wir diesen Messen können hat es sich
nicht verbessert die Unternehmen
finanzieren ihre Investitionen aus ihren
Gewinnen das denken die Leute aber wenn
man sich die 500 größten US-Unternehmen
anguckt werden 50% der Gewinner als
Dividenden ausgeschüttet und 50% für den
Rückkauf von Aktien verwendet wie
finanzieren Sie also Ihre Investitionen
wenn sie sich verschuldet haben
der Präsident zeigte sich gestern
überrascht über den Einbruch der Märkte
seine immer noch anhaltende Popularität
verdankt er dem Wirtschaftsboom den
Amerika unter seiner Führung erlebt hat
es arbeiten mehr Menschen als jemals
zuvor in der Geschichte unsere
Produktivität ist gestiegen es gibt
keine galoppierende Inflation wie in der
Vergangenheit
wie gesagt ich glaube nicht dass jemand
in Panik geraten sollte denn alle
Wirtschaftsindikatoren sind solide
aber die Warnzeichen sind schon lange da
in den geschlossenen Fabriken in vielen
Kleinstädten
es gibt diese Vorstellung von
Milliardären die Arbeitsplätze schaffen
das ist die trickle-down-wirtschaft das
Problem ist dass das in der Geschichte
noch nie passierte ist so etwas wie eine
trickle-down-ökonomie gibt es nicht sie
existiert einfach nicht es ist
wenn man die klügsten Köpfe der Welt in
die Finanzwelt steckt was wir in den
letzten 25 Jahren getan haben kann man
ihre Fantasie und ihre Kreativität nicht
aufhalten
die Geschwindigkeit und das Ausmaß des
globalen wirtschaftlichen Wandels haben
die nationalen regulierungssysteme
überwältigt wir werden eine strengere
und transparentere Überwachung von
Banken Hedgefonds und dem sogenannten
globalen schattenbanken-
nehmen wir an ich bin ein Banker wenn
die Aufsichtsbehörden kommen sind wir
eine sehr einfache kleine Bank sie
schauen sich unsere Verfahren an die Tür
Diligence Prüfung von Projekten die wir
gemacht haben das ist ziemlich einfach
dann gehen Sie zu einer großen Bank Wels
oder JP Morgan oder Goldman und sie als
Aufsichtsbehörde fragen sich was ist das
all diese E-Mails sie verstehen es nicht
weil sie nicht in diesem Bereich
arbeiten das ist so als würde man
versuchen den Leuten die Quanten
Gravitation zu erklären wenn man einen
Highschool für Sie Kurs absolviert hat
und jetzt Stephen Hawking inspizieren
soll
die Erde ist ein reichhaltiges
natürliches System dass ich nicht ewig
ausdehnen kann das schöne am
rechts-system und Derivate sind ein Teil
davon ist dass wir es soweit ausdehnen
können wie wir wollen also schaffen wir
immer neue Arten von Vermögenswerten
letztendlich schaffen wir neue Arten von
juristischen Tricks und die beiden
Systeme sind nicht ohne weiteres
kompatibel
wenn sie reich sind und mit ihrem Geld
spielen und es in Las Vegas verlieren
ist dass Ihr Problem aber wenn Sie Ihr
Geld hier verlieren ist es unser Problem
der Markt kann nicht für Dinge bestrafen
von denen er keine Ahnung hat und sie
haben keines der Risiken einkalkuliert
dass sich das alles ändern könnte
eine Naturkatastrophe könnte große
Auswirkungen auf unser Finanzsystem
haben weil sie sich auf die
Vermögenswerte auswirkt
das neue Gesetz erlaubt es den 12
Federal Reserve banks zusätzliches Geld
für gute Vermögenswerte auszugeben so
dass die Banken die wieder öffnen in der
Lage sein werden jede legitime
Forderungen zu erfüllen es handelt sich
um eine solide Währung weil sie durch
tatsächliche gute Vermögenswerte gedeckt
ist
was also passiert ist dass es eine
Ereignis gibt und wenn das Ereignis
eintritt waren alle auf und plötzlich
gibt es das was wir im Finanzsystem
Ansteckungen nennen die Leute entladen
sich sie stoßen Aktien ab sie versuchen
ihre Derivate zurückzubekommen sie
wollen ihre versicherungspolizen
einlösen und der marktgerät ins Wanken
wenn der Markt zu kollabieren beginnt
werden überall die Stecker gezogen beim
Klimawandel haben wir es also nicht nur
mit den direkten Auswirkungen zu tun
sondern auch mit der Möglichkeit einer
Ansteckung
wirtschaftliche Ansteckung
wirtschaftlich finanziell
diese Ansichten sind nur Prognosen und
werden sich mit dem Eintreffen neuer
Informationen weiterentwickeln
wir haben gesagt dass wir diese
Finanzakteure retten werden wir werden
sie retten das kann nicht
aufrechterhalten werden
es läuft nur weil die Zentralbanken
eingreifen und Vermögenswerte kaufen
dann wurde kürzlich vorgeschlagen dass
die Europäische Zentralbank anfangen
sollte Aktien von Unternehmen zu kaufen
also nicht nur Schulden sondern auch
Aktien wir sozialisieren also die
Verpflichtung finanzerträge für die
Inhaber von Kapitalvermögen zu schaffen
das kann nicht ewig so weitergehen
auch wenn alle Politiker sagen das ist
die wichtigste Wahl deines Lebens werden
diese Kräfte nicht durch eine einzige
Wahl gebändigt oder entfesselt
in den letzten Wochen haben wir in den
Nachrichten über das Corona-Virus
gelesen und China tut so als wäre das
die Zombie-Apokalypse ich habe wirklich
ein bisschen Angst vor dem Coronavirus
ich will auch nicht in ein Flugzeug
steigen aber haben wir eine Regierung
die kompetent genug ist um eine solche
Reaktion zu bewältigen
nein wir können ja nicht einmal mit der
Obdachlosigkeit in l.a umgehen wir
kriegen es nicht einmal hin etwas
richtig zu finanzieren geschweige denn
eine Pandemie
[Musik]
die Amerikaner Leben in der Illusion
dass sie sich total von anderen Menschen
unterscheiden als ich auf dem College
war als auf dem Balkan alles
zusammenschmolz sagten sie diese Leute
sind wilde sie bekämpfen sich schon seit
hunderten von Jahren es ist als ob sie
gerade von den Bäumen heruntergekommen
wären oder so dann ist man dort und
stellt fest dass diese Menschen in
Häusern leben die Strom haben und
Garagen mit zwei Autos und Kühlschränke
und nicht nur Kinder die studieren
sondern mehrere Generationen die
studiert haben und sie sprechen alle
dieselbe Sprache
und diese Menschen haben sich
gegenseitig umgebracht sie haben einen
Völkermord begangen
250.000 tote vergewaltigungslager
Konzentrationslager ethnische Säuberung
der Plan war den Kosovo ethnisch zu
säubern und die albanische Bevölkerung
loszuwerden werden wir das dulden wird
Frankreich das dulden das glaube ich
nicht
wie in vielen Ländern beginnt ein System
zusammenzubrechen in Ihrem Fall war es
das kommunistische System und in unserem
Fall beginnt unser kapitalistisches
System zusammenzubrechen und die
Menschen gehen aufeinander los weil
einige Anführer denken jeder ist gerade
verärgert und ich kann meine Gruppe
motivieren einer anderen Gruppe etwas
wegzunehmen seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
hat Europa nicht mehr so viele
Vertriebene gesehen
und das sind die Dinge über die wir uns
beim Klimawandel Sorgen machen müssen
denn das passiert wenn die Ressourcen
knapp werden und jeder ist ein Mensch
jeder ist anfällig für diese Dinge wir
haben Retter zugesägt die wir vor die
Fenster machten für den Fall das
Plünderer kommen um das Haus zu schützen
die Vereinten Nationen sagten erst vor
zwei Wochen eine Milliarde innerhalb von
30 Jahren eine Milliarde vertriebene
weil sie wegen der Dürre oder
Überschwemmungen oder des Zusammenbruchs
von Systemen ihre Nahrungsmitteln nicht
mehr so anbauen können wie früher wie
viel schlimmer wird es noch werden bevor
es besser wird
die allgemeine Ansicht ist dass sich die
Lage vorerst weiter verschlechtern wird
die nächsten Regenfälle werden noch eine
Weile auf sich warten lassen
für die Welt ist das eine sehr schlimme
Sache denn es geht um Milliarden von
Menschen die umgesiedelt werden und um
massive wirtschaftliche Folgen
kann eine Gesellschaft die in
materieller Hinsicht so erfolgreich war
wie diese sich selbst verändern in der
Vergangenheit waren Imperium nicht in
der Lage das zu tun
was würden diese Römer sagen könnten Sie
uns helfen
unwahrscheinlich unwahrscheinlich
[Musik]
das Erbe Amerikas ist römisch weißt du
die Männer die die Verfassung
geschrieben haben haben die Geschichte
Roms studiert der Senat ist er ist
römisch und er versagt so wie der
römische Senat versagt hat es gab einen
griechischen Philosophen der sagte das
Regierungen Zyklen durchlaufen
sie gehen von der Demokratie über das
Oligopol zur
Diktatur und brechen dann zusammen
du sprichst von Aristoteles das war
nicht der Aristoteles das war jemand
anderes nein es war es totes nein es war
vielleicht polypius ich habe es
vergessen ich wette mit dir um Geld das
ist Aristoteles ist weil wir in Vegas
sind ich wette mit dir um Bargeld dass
es Aristoteles ist
aristoteles hat die drei Arten von
Regierungen und ihre Alter Egos
definiert
es gibt eine Demokratie die wenn sie
schlecht läuft zu einer mobokratie wird
es gibt eine Monarchie die wenn sie
schief geht zur Tyrannei wird
und es gibt eine Aristokratie die wenn
sie schlecht läuft zu einem Oligopol
wird
er baut auf der Arbeit eines Vorgängers
auf wie lautet der Name des Vorgängers
das müssen wir herausfinden
ich weiß es nicht sag's mir wir finden
es raus ich weiß es nicht ich muss es
Nachschlagen Reichtum wurde vor allem
durch den Handel erlangt
in die Lagerhäuser strömten waren aus
dem ganzen Reich und darüber hinaus es
waren eher die wenigen Reichen als die
vielen die von den Reichtümern und
enormen Ressourcen des Reiches
profitierten
dieses Ungleichgewicht und das
unverantwortliche Verhalten der Beamten
sollten zu den Hauptgründen für den
Niedergang Roms werden
war das nicht letzte Woche in den
Nachrichten
also Dad und ich hatten diese Wette und
du musst herausfinden ob ich recht habe
oder er
es geht um Aristoteles
ich weiß ich weiß also ich dachte mir
naja es totes beschreibt den Tod der
Demokratie und was mit verschiedenen
Regierungsformen passiert wenn sie
zerfallen
im Mittelalter vor allem zu Beginn und
während des Übergangs zum Mittelalter in
der spät Antike nahm die soziale
Ungleichheit stärker zu als je zuvor
[Musik]
wurden immer reicher und die Armen immer
ärmer der Grund dafür liegt darin dass
das römische Reich und seine
Zentralregierung den ärmsten Teil der
Bevölkerung nicht unterstützten was sie
vorher noch getan hatten
das selbe Muster lässt sich auch in der
heutigen Gesellschaft beobachten
die Mittelschicht ist besonders
betroffen und leidet immer mehr unter
der Rezession die wir seit Anfang der
2000er Jahre erleben
ich weiß auch aus deinen Studien dass
der Zusammenbruch des Römischen Reiches
vor allem ein riesiger enormer
gigantischer finanzieller Zusammenbruch
war
irgendwann einfach das Geld aus
es gibt viele verschiedene Theorien
warum das römische Reich
zusammengebrochen ist was wir heute
wissen ist dass es einen langen
wirtschaftlichen Niedergang gab bevor
die deutschen Horden kamen und Italien
und schließlich Rom eroberten
die Frage ist also was hat den langen
wirtschaftlichen Niedergang ausgelöst
die Ungleichheit zwischen den Reichen
und den
armeniores ja du sprichst jetzt Latein
ja Latein
massive Ungleichheit kann politisch
nicht nachhaltig sein Regierungen
finanzieren sich entweder durch Schulden
oder durch Steuern
in Rom würde man im Grunde versuchen
mehr Erträge aus den besetzten Provinzen
herauszuholen oder man würde einen
weiteren Krieg beginnen um die Erträge
zu erhalten die Rom ernähren und
diejenigen ernähren die das System
insgesamt betreiben ich glaube das ist
der gemeinsame Nenner denn wir leben
heute in einem ganz anderen System heute
sind es unsere Zentralbanken die die
Rettungsaktion durchführen
eine der wirklichen Stärken der
Finanzmärkte besteht darin dass sie
Maßnahmen aus der Zukunft in die
Gegenwart verlagern können wenn es eine
glaubwürdige Politik gibt schließlich
ist das meiste was die Zentralbanken tun
genau das
große Bäume fallen schwer der Markt kann
sich an alles anpassen solange es
Klarheit Transparenz und Ehrlichkeit
gibt und ich glaube nicht dass wir das
bekommen
es gab eine Menge Dinge die das Problem
verursacht haben aber im Wesentlichen
hat die Struktur Roms lange Zeit
zusammengehalten bis ihr schließlich die
wirtschaftlichen Möglichkeiten und die
Führung ausgingen
Politiker wurden gekauft die Gründer
unserer Republik haben uns immer wieder
davor gewarnt dass wenn man wirklich
reich wird und seinen moralischen
Charakter verliert es vorbei ist genau
da sind wir jetzt weil wir sehr nahe an
einem Moment sind in dem wir anfangen
könnten langsam abzurutschen und wenn
wir nicht sehr vorsichtig sind werden
wir schneller und schneller und
schneller und schneller und schneller
Achterbahn das wird eine Menge Spaß
machen vielleicht sie kennen den alten
Fluch mögen sie in interessanten Zeiten
leben
so
ist es also beim letzten mal ausgegangen
nur dass es diesmal nicht nur Barbaren
sind sondern es ist der Planet selbst
der in Flammen aufgeht
es gibt hier immer noch ein aktives
Feuer behalten Sie die Lage im Auge und
informieren Sie sich was Sie tun müssen
wenn das Feuer näher kommt
in den rauchigen Nachwehen des
schlimmsten Staats in die feuersaison an
dem man sich erinnern kann suchen die
einen nach Lösungen die anderen nach
einem Schuldigen
vielleicht sollten wir eine Pause
einlegen damit sich alles einspielen
kann
finanzieller Einfallsreichtum ist Teil
dieses Systems seit die Niederländer die
Gesellschaft mit beschränkter Haftung
erfunden haben okay aber ein Großteil
davon ist nicht finanziell aber Papa
hört zu jeder dachte Burney Madoff sei
ein Genie
ausländische Investoren schauten auf die
USA und sagten die Vereinigten Staaten
sind ja sicherste Ort auf der Welt an
dem ich mein Geld anlegen kann
wir hatten ich weiß nicht fünf sechs
biblische Ereignisse wir werden Sie auch
weiterhin haben
ich muss also den Wert und die
Rentabilität meines Landes auf lange
Sicht in Frage stellen
vor etwas mehr als sieben Jahren fegte
der Hurrikan Sandy hier durch und
verursachte Sachschäden in Höhe von
mehreren Milliarden Dollar und seitdem
hat New York mehr größere höhere und
teurere Gebäude gebaut
weil wir die Menschen für die Kosten der
Versicherung aufkommen müssen falls ein
weiterer Hurrikan New York City trifft
das nationale
hochwasserversicherungsprogramm ist
staatlich und öffentlich es wird von der
nationalen Katastrophenhilfe verwaltet
es bietet hochwasserversicherungen für
praktisch alle Hausbesitzer und
Kleinunternehmen im Land das ist also
eigentlich ziemlich ungewöhnlich in den
meisten anderen Ländern gibt es private
Märkte für hochwasserversicherung in den
USA
[Musik]
es handelt sich um eine
Zusatzversicherung die von der Regierung
subventionierte
bis zu einem gewissen Grad die Rechnung
für die Eigentümer von Immobilien an der
Küste bezahlen
um eine riesige Wohnanlage in einem
Überschwemmungsgebiet in New York City
zu bauen braucht man natürlich eine
Menge Kapital die kommunalen Akteure in
New York City sind sehr darin
interessiert weiterhin eine Version von
New York City zu fördern in der ein
möglichst großer Teil des verfügbaren
Landes für die weitere wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung nutzbar bleiben
das nationale
hochwasserversicherungsprogramm sollte
ursprünglich den Bau von Gebäuden in
sehr gefährdeten Gebieten stoppen in
Gebieten in denen sich das Wasser mit
hoher Geschwindigkeit bewegt vor allem
in Überschwemmungsgebieten entlang des
Flusses in denen sich das Wasser mit der
gleichen Geschwindigkeit wieder Fluss
bewegt und in Hurricane in denen die
Sturmflut ankommt es ist fast unmöglich
ein sicheres Gebäude zu bauen das einer
zwei Meter hohen Wasserwand standhält
die bei einer Sturmflut auf einen
zukommt es gibt viele Interessengruppen
denen das egal ist zum Beispiel die
Bauindustrie sie würden gerne ein Haus
am Strand bauen solange sie es verkaufen
können bevor die Flut kommt
und wenn sie es dann verkauft haben
liegt das Risiko bei jemand anderem
die Art und Weise wie die Finanzakteure
im Vorfeld der letzten Finanzkrise
Hypotheken verbrieft haben ist immer
noch aktuell
die Bauunternehmer wollen alle das
hochwasserprogramm Minimieren die Stadt
will es minimieren will die Pegelstände
auf den Karten klein halten und kämpft
gegen jede Karte die vom
hochwasserversicherungsprogramm
herausgegeben wird das führt zu
Verzögerung bei der Umsetzung vielleicht
sogar zur nicht Umsetzung
die Christengemeinden befinden sich in
einigen der wertvollsten Gegenden des
Landes und deshalb werden die Menschen
kämpfen um ihre Investitionen zu
schützen
ich dachte okay die Stadt verlangt nicht
dass ich eine hochwasserversicherung
habe mein Immobilienmakler hat mir nicht
gesagt dass ich eine haben muss
ehrlich gesagt schaut man sich die
hochwasserkarten nicht an wenn man
irgendwo hinzieht man verliebt sich
einfach in das Haus und 85% meiner
Nachbarn waren nicht versichert
die USA sind besonders anfällig dafür in
Katastrophen gefährdeten physisch
gefährdeten Gebieten zu bauen weil wir
uns auf lokale Regeln verlassen
vor allem bei Entscheidungen über die
Raumordnung
das gehört zu den Grundlagen der
Vereinigten Staaten zu den Rechten der
Bundesstaaten und zu den Rechten der
Kommunen
und das hat viele Vorteile aber auch
einen großen Nachteil die Kommunen sind
auf Einnahmen angewiesen die von ihren
Gebäuden von ihren Einwohnern stammen
die in ihren Orten bauen und leben
und das bedeutet dass alle Einwohner von
der Entwicklung profitieren
ist in den USA so stark mit den
Grundstückswerten verknüpft das wenn die
Grundstückswerte sinken die
steuerveranlagungen entsprechend
angepasst werden und man weniger
Einnahmen für die Steuerbasis erzählt
was weniger Investitionen in lokale
Einrichtungen Schulen und den
öffentlichen Nahverkehr bedeutet
in Texas in Texas haben wir keine
staatliche Einkommenssteuer das ist ein
weiterer Grund warum man hier leben
möchte denn es ist billig aber die Leute
werden auf ihr Land besteuert
the maps die bestehenden Karten die
zeigen wo ein Hundert oder 500
jährliches Hochwasser auftritt sind so
veraltet und ungenau dass das Risiko und
die Kosten dieses Risikos selbst in der
Versicherungsbranche nicht so genau sind
wie sie sein müssten damit wir die
Kosten des Klimas einschätzen können
die Versicherungs Akteure haben Wege
gefunden um eine versicherungspolis zu
verbieten und sie auf die
risikokapitalmärkte zu übertragen
das bedeutet dass Sie bereit sind mehr
und mehr Immobilien zu versichern was
wiederum bedeutet dass die Leute
weiterhin in risikoreichen Gebieten
bauen
ich glaube nicht dass irgendjemand ein
Haus angucken will wenn er dafür durch
Salzwasser kommen muss und es dann auch
noch kaufen will
das ist meine
Kinder und meinen Ruhestand ja aber
jetzt wo Du es in einem Gebiet gekauft
hast in dem der Meeresspiegel steigt ist
dieser Notgroschen vielleicht nicht mehr
so sicher
und um seine Notgroschen in Bargeld
umzuwandeln muss er in der Lage sein das
Haus zu verkaufen
aber jetzt wird niemand mehr die
30-Jährige Hypothek versichern was
passiert mit John
hat seine Notgroschen verloren okay also
john ist jetzt buchstäblich John auf der
Straße
das schöne Haus das sie in Florida
kaufen wollten um sich zur Ruhe zu
setzen werden sie nicht das war ihr Haus
in Florida sie wollten nach Alabama
umziehen okay nun sie werden nicht
umziehen vielleicht nach Alabama aber
sie werden dort in einem Wohnwagen leben
bei Überschwemmungen ist die
US-Regierung auf ganz besondere Weise
beteiligt Feuer wird privat versichert
ernst was mit dem feuerrisiko passiert
ist das einige Erstversicherer ihre
Geschäft aufgeben müssen euer
Ereignissen wie den Waldbränden in
Kalifornien muss ein Versicherer sein
Geschäft aufgeben wenn seine
ausstehenden Verbindlichkeiten höher
sind als die Summe die er auszahlen kann
dann haben wir uns unterhalten und sie
haben ja erzählt dass sie ein Haus in
Sausalito kaufen wollten was ist dann
passiert wir riefen bei der Versicherung
an zwei oder drei Tage vorher und ließen
sie wissen dass wir bald unterschreiben
würden und sie sagten hey wir können das
Haus nicht versichern und wir fragen was
und sie sagten ja es steht auf einer
Liste von vierteln die wir nicht mehr
versichern also werden diese ganzen
Stadtteile nicht versichert sein und sie
sagten uns auch dass sie nicht wissen ob
sie den derzeitigen Besitzer des Hauses
wiederversichern werden da sind Häuser
am Wert von Milliarden von Dollar im
ganzen Bundesstaat ihren
versicherungsproblem haben werden
die Versicherungsgesellschaften
versichern nur für ein Jahr wenn sich
die Lage also verschlimmert werden die
Gesellschaften definitiv nicht in der
Lage sein den Hausbesitzern zu Hilfe zu
kommen
diese latenten versteckten klima-risiken
die an verschiedenen Orten in
verschiedenen Wohnungsmärkten bestehen
könnten sollten sie platzen das gesamte
Finanzsystem zum Einsturz bringen
im Moment ist dieses Haus für 49.000
Dollar gelistet auf dem Höhepunkt des
Marktes lag der Preis bei 250000
es sind nicht nur die Eigentümer die ihr
Vermögen verlieren sondern auch die
Vermittler die ihre Forderungen gegen
sie verlieren es sind diejenigen die die
verbrieften Hypotheken und
Vermögenswerte gekauft haben die wir in
der Krise 2008 gesehen haben
wenn wir nicht bereit sind immer wieder
den gleichen Scheck auszustellen müssen
wir anfangen zu prüfen ob wir die
Versorgungseinrichtungen und die
Infrastruktur um diese Häuser herum
ausreichend verstärken damit sie diese
Stürme in Zukunft überstehen können
oder sollten wir die Investition von
Kapital das den Bedingungen des
Klimawandels in negativerweise
ausgesetzt sein wird tatsächlich nicht
zulassen darüber müssen wir
nachdenkende denn wir sind nicht ich
meine sie wissen ja dass unsere
Infrastruktur nicht dafür gerüstet ist
noch nicht das ist sehr teuer manche
Leute denken darüber nach aber bisher
hat das niemand getan
vom Standpunkt eines Ölunternehmens aus
betrachtet befinden sich die meisten
großen Anlagen in den USA und eigentlich
weltweit an der Küste
aus dieser Sicht sind die Anlagen
genauso gefährdet wie die Häuser der
Menschen im Golf von Mexiko gibt es eine
Menge offshore-infrastruktur die jedoch
an Land in viele Pipelines mündet die
direkt an der Küste liegen
wenn also die Küstenlinie erodiert
werden diese Pipeline sichtbar und
anfällig und müssen tiefer vergraben
oder mit einer Infrastruktur umgeben
werden um sie zu schützen
also die Stärkung der Infrastruktur der
Versorgungseinrichtungen Brände die
damit oder mit den Pipelines in
Verbindung gebracht werden die Menschen
machen sich Sorgen darüber wie es mit
dem Schutz weitergeht
die Natur wird die Grundlage unserer
Wirtschaft aushöhlen
manchmal bin ich an einem Ort wie diesen
und stelle mir vor wie es wäre ohne Geld
in der Tasche vor einem wirtschaftlichen
Zusammenbruch hierher zu fliehen
[Musik]
denn wissen Sie wir haben viel Land aber
wenn ich hier draußen überleben müsste
und kein Geld hätte um mir etwas zu
kaufen das mich mit Strom versorgt eine
Möglichkeit Wasser aus seinem ziemlich
trockenen Land zu holen während wir die
unberührte Natur lieben und gerne in ihr
wandern jagen Zelten
all diese Dinge die wir dank der
Technologie tun die sie im Laden gekauft
haben das Zelt das Gewehr die
Taschenlampe das Feuerzeug
diese Dinge werden im menschlichen
Gemeinschaften hergestellt in Fabriken
nicht von Menschen auf der Flucht nicht
von Menschen die kein Kapital haben
es dreht sich alles ums Kapital
also passiert folgendes das Kapital wird
dorthin fließen wo es für den Kapital
Aigner das meiste Geld einbringen kann
eine Stadt wie diese die eine
silberminenstadt war ist ein gutes
Beispiel für die Theorie der
Nahrungssuche wenn du ein Tier bist oder
diese Dinge lassen sich auch auf die
menschliche Welt übertragen du hast die
Wahl zwischen zwei Dingen einem das
leicht zu bekommen ist und einem das
schwer zu bekommen ist wenn das leicht
zu bekommende Ding mehr wert ist dann
wirst du dich dafür entscheiden das ist
es was die boomstätte hervorbringt denn
zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt war das
Silber wirklich leicht zu bekommen und
etwas wert und dann als der Silbermarkt
zusammenbrach war es nichts mehr wert
also ging man weiter um die nächste
leicht zu fördernde Sache zu finden
diese Muster des Kapitals ändern sich
nicht im Laufe der Zeit
das Kapital wird immer nach der größten
Rendite Streben und sobald sich diese
Rendite nicht auszahlt wird man die
Zelte abbrechen und woanders hingehen
wie man Kapital definiert es ist das
Geld dass man verwendet um etwas zu
schaffen
die Leute sind sehr kurzsichtig sie
schauen nur auf das was sie vor Augen
haben und auf das Portfolio direkt vor
Ihnen wie Sie kurzfristig Geld verdienen
können
also wissen Sie wir schauen uns um und
das ist das ganze Kapital das ganze
Kapital der Welt das genau hier seinen
Sitz hat und ich nehme an dass wir alle
über 50 hinaus leben wollen und deshalb
müssen wir uns umstellen schlagen die
sich darum bei ihnen investieren zu
dürfen
nein das tun sie nicht wir müssen nach
der richtigen Art von Investoren für
unsere Projekte suchen und wenn wir die
Investoren gefunden haben ist es extrem
schwierig den Wert zu schaffen oder den
Wert für unsere Projekte herauszuholen
den die Investoren sofort erkennen
15 Prozent auf sein Geld bekommen kann
warum sollte er dann fünf Prozent bei
erneuerbaren Energien wollen weil er die
Steuergutschrift für Investitionen
nutzen könnte jeder will eine Rendite
und jeder will seine Rendite maximieren
und die einzigen von denen ich weiß dass
sie ihre Rendite für Projekte im Bereich
der erneuerbaren Energien maximieren
können sind die Wohlhabenden
Einzelpersonen die ein passives
Einkommen haben und was verstehen wir
unter wohlhabenden Personen ich glaube
viele Amerikaner denken wenn jemand
500.000 Dollar hat ist der Vorabend wir
reden über Leute die Hunderte von
Millionen Dollar an Nettovermögen haben
also mindestens hunderte Millionen
Dollar an Nettovermögen das würde ich so
sagen aber es gibt nicht viele Leute
vielleicht weniger als ein Prozent der
Bevölkerung die diese Art von
Investitionen haben die ein passives
Einkommen generieren
wenn es keine Investitionen auf dem
Markt in Richtung der Technologie gibt
die zu Klima Lösungen erneuerbaren
Energien und sauberer Energie beitragen
würde dann wirkt sich das auf den
gesamten Lebenszyklus aus auf den
gesamten geschäftsfluss
der Gründer der Makroökonomie stellte
die Frage warum investieren die Menschen
ehrlich gesagt gibt es darauf keine
Antwort er nannte es animal spirits ich
kann Ihnen sagen die Menschen sind
Risikoscheu und nach 2018 sind sie sogar
noch Risiko scheuer wenn ich zu diesem
Wirtschaftskonferenzen gehe und meine
Freunde sehe frage ich den Typen der 100
Millionen Dollar hat woran arbeiten sie
jetzt wer antwortet ich bin zufrieden wo
ich bin ich habe ein Haus in Mexiko und
wir kümmern uns um die Enkelkinder ich
eine er investiert nicht in Risiken er
schafft keine Arbeitsplätze für den Rest
von uns zumindest nicht direkt das ist
der animal Spirit der derzeit in vielen
Unternehmen herrscht das kann man nur
durch staatliche Führung ersetzen
der eure Kanal die transkontinentale
Eisenbahn der Panamakanal das
Weltraumprogramm das Interstate Highway
System in keinem Fall hat sich eine
Gruppe von Unternehmern zusammengetan
und gesagt hey lasst uns das Interstate
Highway System bauen nein es war ein
Traum den Eisenhauer 1955 vorantrieb der
aus einer Studie während des Zweiten
Weltkriegs hervorging die zeigte dass
man diese Autobahnen für die nationale
Sicherheit brauchte
das ist keine Parteipolitik niemand hat
ein Monopol auf die Wahrheit und auf die
Fakten die dieses Land betreffen wir
müssen zusammenarbeiten
die USA sind sehr uneinheitlich wir
haben Bundesstaaten Bezirke Regionen
Zehntausende von Städten und alle haben
einen Mitspracherecht es ist schwer uns
dazu zu bringen bei bestimmten Projekten
zusammenzuarbeiten es sei denn wir sind
uns daran einig dass es notwendig ist
und dringend gemacht werden muss wenn
die australische militärstudie die
us-militärstudie und die britische
militär-studie alle korrekt sind haben
wir wenn wir nichts tun etwa 30 Jahre
Zeit bis die Zivilisation zusammenbricht
was vermutlich keine gute Rendite hat
korrekt wir sind diejenigen die Ihnen
sagen dass wir den Kipppunkt bereits
überschritten haben können
ich glaube das übrigens nicht
wenn Sie das glauben dann ist die
Investition in Wind und Solarenergie
fast nicht mehr relevant
[Musik]
was ist das wertvollste auf der Welt es
sind die Ölreserven im Boden
sie sind mehrwerter als das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt der Vereinigten
Staaten mehr als der Aktienmarkt mehr
als die Aktienmärkte aller westlichen
Länder es ist Öl im Boden und die
Menschen die dieses Öl haben wollen dass
es genutzt wird was immer sie über
Saudi-Arabien hören sie werden sich von
einer erdölbasierten Wirtschaft
wegbewegen ja ja aber sie werden sich in
ihrem Tempo bewegen und sie brauchen
diese pedro-dollars um dorthin zu
gelangen
die gesellschaftlichen Kosten sind im
Moment viel höher als die
wirtschaftlichen Kosten für die Entnahme
von Öl aus dem Boden also muss man die
gesellschaftlichen Auswirkungen erkennen
und die Leute die es produzieren und
verkaufen und die Leute die es kaufen
dazu bringen die vollen Kosten für seine
Nutzung zu zahlen das heißt eine Steuer
aber das haben wir noch nicht mal bei
der Sicherheit gemacht ich meine
realistisch betrachtet haben wir die
Ölindustrie 50 Jahre lang subventioniert
indem wir Regierungen umgestoßen haben
indem wir die Schifffahrtswege für sie
geschützt haben die ölwege also konnten
wir es nicht einmal tun wenn es darum
ging sie für ihre eigene Förderung und
Sicherheit zahlen zu lassen das stimmt
aber einer der Gründe warum wir es nicht
tun konnten ist dass wir nicht wirklich
eine Alternative hatten was ist das für
ein Geräusch wir hatten nicht wirklich
die Alternative technisch
Ingenieure arbeiten unter Beschuss um
Ölleitungen zu löschen die von denen
sich zurückziehenden irakischen Truppen
in Brand gesetzt worden waren
tierische Fette und Talk konnten den
ständig wachsenden Bedarf an Kerzen und
Schmiermittel nicht mehr decken das
Walöl das lange Zeit das wichtigste
Leuchtmittel war wurde knapp doch die
Nachfrage nach künstlichem Licht stieg
im Jahr 1850 wurde eine Lampe erfunden
die ein raffiniertes Erdölprodukt
effizient verbrannte
bei der frühen Ölförderung wurde
Dampfkraft verwendet und die wurde
wahrscheinlich durch die Verbrennung von
Holz oder Kohle erzeugt man braucht also
Holz oder Kohle um Öl zu gewinnen heute
nutzen wir Elektrizität oder Gas um Öl
zu gewinnen wir nutzen also eine
Energieform um eine andere zu gewinnen
wir haben keine Wirtschaft die nur von
einer Energieform lebt sondern eine die
von vielen Formen lebt
ein Teil dieser Gleichung ist die
Anpassung des Konsums und des
kulturellen Verhaltens aber darüber wird
nicht geredet keiner will jemandem die
Schuld geben wenn man der Industrie die
Schuld geben will nun die Industrie
existiert weil die Menschen ihre Dinge
kaufen oder benutzen sie sind also die
Endverbraucher sollen wir sie mit einer
kohlenstoffsteuer bestrafen vielleicht
sollten wir alle Verantwortung
übernehmen und einen Kulturwandel
herbeiführen um dahin zurückzukehren wo
wir vor 30 40 Jahren waren vielleicht
aber das ist schwer der überwiegende
Teil unseres individuellen Ausstoßes
kommt aus den Bereichen wohnen Verkehr
und Ernährung das sind große
strukturelle Probleme die man nicht
wirklich adäquat angehen kann indem man
die Marke der Papierhandtücher wechselt
die man kauft
wir leben in einer
energieverbrauchsgesellschaft
und wir müssen uns darüber im Klaren
sein dass es nichts umsonst gibt
man muss sich darüber bewusst sein dass
alles Energie kostet egal was man tut
[Musik]
so sieht der öffentliche Raum in den USA
nicht aus aber mir ist aufgefallen dass
hier in den Niederlanden jeder überall
mit dem Fahrrad fährt das tun sie ja
und dafür braucht man komischerweise
keinen Benzin
nein
[Musik]
die Frage ist können wir fossile
Brennstoffe durch erneuerbare Energien
ersetzen
und das ist eine sehr heikle Frage sie
löst enorme Debatten aus und die Leute
werden wütend wenn man ihn diese Frage
stellt weil nicht klar ist was man meint
dass man die Gier der Menschen mit
erneuerbaren Energien befriedigen kann
dann lautet die Antwort nein
wenn Sie meinen dass erneuerbare
Energien eine ausreichende Menge an
Energie erzeugen können um zu überleben
dann ist die Antwort ja
wir sind jetzt in einem
energieeffizienten Haus dass wir
umgebaut haben das allein unser
haushaltsverbrauch doppelt so hoch ist
wie der des Durchschnitts Amerikaners
das hat mich wachgerüttelt
ich kann gar nicht zählen wie viele
Reisen nicht aus geschäftlichen Gründen
um die Welt gemacht habe
und zwei internationale Reisen
entsprechen dem Energieverbrauch eines
Jahres in meinem Haus
das hat mich wirklich zum Nachdenken
über das Reisen gebracht das hat mich
dazu gebracht darüber nachzudenken was
ich esse
eine weitere Überraschung für viele
Menschen ist wie viel Energie wir für
Lebensmittel verbrauchen
in den USA verbrauchen wir jährlich 100
Quadrillionen BTU an Energie BTU ist
einer britische Wärmeeinheit und
entspricht etwa dem Energiegehalt eines
Streichholzes wir verbrauchen also 100
Milliarden Millionen Streichhölzer pro
Jahr
10 Quadrillionen BTU sind für das
lebensmittelsystem eines dieser
Quadrillionen steckt in den
Lebensmitteln selbst jedes Jahr nehmen
330 Millionen Amerikaner ein Vierfaches
an Nahrungsenergie in ihren Körper auf
die anderen neuen Quads entfallen auf
den Rest des lebensmittelsystems
Düngemittel Pestizide Diesel für die
Traktoren die Kühlung Trocknung der
Ernte Lagerhäuser Transport und die
Energie für das Kochen zu Hause
drei oder vier Quadrillionen sind nur
für die Kühlkette vom kühllastwagen bis
zu den Kühlschränken bei uns zu Hause
die USA verbrauchen hierfür mehr Energie
als ganze Länder wie die Schweiz und
Schweden zusammen in einem Jahr
die Energie die in den genießbaren
Lebensmitteln steckt die wir wegwerfen
reicht aus um ganze Länder zu versorgen
wir werfen etwa ein Viertel bis die
Hälfte unserer Lebensmittel weg
also Maike wir sind von Wasser umgeben
wie ist die Beziehung zwischen Wasser
und Energie
zum einen verwenden wir eine Menge
Wasser für die Energiegewinnung um
Kraftwerke zu kühlen um Biokraftstoffe
zu bewässern wir verwenden Wasser für
die Öl- und Gasförderung für die
Dampferzeugung in Raffinerien in der
energieversorgungskette ist Wasser in
jedem Schritt enthalten unser Brunnen
ist trocken tot ja das ist tot hier war
das Wasser es ging bis hierhin
das ist keine Fantasy Apokalypse
Filmlandschaft es ist jetzt und es ist
real
das Netz könnte belastet werden wenn es
kein Wasser zum Kühlen gibt zumindest
bei den meisten Kraftwerken die mit
Wärme Arbeiten moderne Formen wie
Solarzellen und Windturbinen brauchen
keine Wasserkühlung wie lange ist die
durchschnittliche Lebensdauer von
Solarpaneelen 20 Jahre 20 25 Jahre 25
vielleicht 30 die Leute sagen also naja
man braucht sieben Jahre Energie um
dieses Panel zu produzieren aber dann
bekommt man 18 Jahre Energie umsonst
also hat man gespart selbst dann bekommt
man 18 Jahre Energie umsonst ja so also
ich und John Cube public wir sagen hey
ich möchte Geld in deine Solarfarm
stecken nein nicht bevor sich die
Regierung einmischt und uns in eine
Paribas Superposition gegenüber fossilen
Brennstoffen bringt
ich habe viele Freunde die in der
Branche der erneuerbaren Energien
arbeiten und da gibt es ein wirklich
großes Problem man hat den
stromabnahmevertrag alle Genehmigungen
sogar Verbund Vereinbarungen aber dann
verzögern die Netzbetreiber die
Inbetriebnahme was ist da los
naja wer hat Zugang zu Infrastruktur die
Demokratisierung der Infrastruktur ist
eine Möglichkeit sie zu öffnen damit
mehr Lösungen entwickelt werden können
das haben wir in den 80er Jahren bei der
Telekommunikation mit AT&T gemacht die
mussten ihre Infrastruktur für andere
Unternehmen öffnen deshalb gibt es jetzt
so viele Telefongesellschaften das
gleiche könnte mit der Demokratisierung
der elektrischen Infrastruktur passieren
dann gäbe es mehr Wind und Solarenergie
und wir hätten mehr Technologien auf dem
Weg dorthin dafür sind langfristige
Planung und stabile Regierungen wirklich
wichtig
was ich so höre ist dass es kein
technologisches Problem ist es ist kein
technisches Problem nein es ist ein
finanztechnisches Problem
Energiearmut Nahrungsmittel Knappheit
Einkommensungleichheit es liegt also
jetzt an uns die Politik zu gestalten
die helfen wird diese Kluft zu
überbrücken
als die USA 1941 in den Krieg zogen
sammelten die Menschen Blechdosen und
Aluminium Frauen hörten auf Neil und
Strümpfe zu kaufen alles wurde für
diesen Kriegseinsatz getan aber der
Krieg war da er war direkt vor unserer
Nase junge Männer wurden eingezogen und
nach Übersee geschickt es gab viele Tote
in der Heimat das ist etwas anderes es
erfordert die gleiche Art von
Umstrukturierung oder Engagement warum
haben Sie nicht mich gefragt ich hätte
doch was tun können
[Musik]
das war damals und das ist heute schauen
Sie sich unser neues los an das Okay
lösungslos suchen Sie etwas das einfach
ist und in ihrer Preisklasse liegt
schauen Sie sich unsere gebrauchten
Lösungen an wie das Wechseln einer
Glühbirne oder zur Arbeit zu laufen oder
unsere mittleren Angebote wie
regenerative Landwirtschaft oder ein
Preis für Kohlenstoff oder lassen Sie
sich von einer Vielzahl brandneuer
Lösungen begeistern wie zum Beispiel die
Auslagerung des klimarisikos aus dem
Derivate Markt oder die Millionen Meilen
Batterie die bald auf den Markt kommt
hören Sie einfach auf einen unserer
zufriedenen Kunden Michael sie sind
jetzt für die Energiepolitik der USA
zuständig und haben freie Hand wie
würden Sie den Übergang Gestalten
aus Gründen der nationalen Sicherheit
des Umweltschutzes und aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen müssen wir
unser Netz verbessern und ausbauen
vielleicht sogar unter Nutzung der
Interstate Highways wir haben bereits
die Rechte und legen Leitungen dann
würde sich ausdehnen und bis zu den
sonnigen Gebieten reichen und an die
städtischen Gebiete angeschlossen
sobald wir das Netz haben können wir
anschließen was wir wollen aber wir
müssen einen Preis für die Verschmutzung
festlegen dann nehmen wir das Geld um
die Müllbeseitigung zu bezahlen die USA
Blasen jedes Jahr 6 Milliarden Tonnen
CO2 in die Atmosphäre wenn wir 30 Dollar
pro Tonne zahlen um sie zu entfernen
macht das 180 Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr
das ist weniger als das was wir allein
für die Müllbeseitigung in den Städten
ausgeben warum nicht noch ein paar
hundert Milliarden für die Beseitigung
des Mülls in der Atmosphäre ausgeben wir
sollten das CO2 in den Boden einbringen
die Landwirte dafür bezahlen dass sie
CO2 aus der Atmosphäre in den Boden
einbringen
wir brauchen mehr von dieser nationalen
sicherheitsmentalität
wenn man eine Bild to laststrategie hat
dann sollte man sich ansehen was in
diesen längeren Zeiträumen passiert das
ist absolut entscheidend
wir werden alle Energie Formen und alle
Menschen brauchen um diesen Übergang zu
bewältigen
[Musik]
ich versuche dieses Auto loszuwerden
aber es ist wie mit dem Rauchen
aufzuhören verstehen sie es ist nicht
einfach man hat sich so sehr an
bestimmte Dinge gewöhnt dass es sehr
schwierig ist
die Römer haben dem Ökosystem viel
Schlimmes angetan aber sie haben es
nicht so zerstört wie wir es könnten
der Katastrophenschutz schätzt dass man
für jeden Dollar der für die
Gefahrenabwehr ausgegeben wird 4 Dollar
an Kosten für die Wiederherstellung nach
einer Katastrophe spart wir geben das
Geld also bereits aus es gibt das Gefühl
dass es vielleicht zu teuer ist sich auf
den Klimawandel vorzubereiten aber wir
geben das Geld bereits aus wir geben es
nach jeder Katastrophe aus
wissen Sie als ich aufgewachsen bin gab
es die Wehrpflicht jeder dachte er sei
im Land verpflichtet wenn man auf ein
Land grand College ging wurde man
eingezogen heute ist das anders das
Vertrauen in die Regierung ist weg die
Verpflichtung gegenüber der Regierung
ist verschwunden wenn wir nur etwas von
diesem Geist des Patriotismus nehmen und
ihn wieder aufbauen könnten um etwas für
die Umwelt zu tun
dieses ganze Ding ist aus Kohlenstoff
gebaut der aus der Atmosphäre kommt
[Musik]
wir brauchen hunderttausend junge Leute
die einen Teil ihres Sommers opfern um
sich zu formieren und wirklich daran zu
arbeiten wir könnten diese pinienkäfer
die den Wald zerstören bekämpfen wir
könnten neue Bäume pflanzen aber das
sollte nicht nur gegen Bezahlung
geschehen sondern auch aus der
Verpflichtung jedes Bürgers heraus sich
um das Land zu kümmern das ist es was
ich gerne sehen würde das klingt als
wollten sie eine ganze Generation von
Menschen dafür begeistern das klingt wie
etwas das alte Männer sagen würden
das hat mich dazu gebracht ihr zuliebe
mehr zu kämpfen die Verwandlung ist
aufregend weil wir nicht nur darüber
nachdenken sollten Dinge zu verlieren
die wir immer gewollt haben sondern auch
über das Loslassen von Dingen von denen
wir vielleicht nicht profitieren wir
können verlieren um uns in etwas anderes
zu verwandeln wir sind nicht so
zuversichtlich dass alles gut wird aber
wir finden Möglichkeiten dass sich die
Dinge auch wirklich dramatische Weise
verändern
die Geschichte lehrt uns dass es viele
verschiedene Zivilisationen und
unterschiedliche Wirtschaftssysteme und
Handelsformen gibt daher war das
Mittelalter einfach eine andere Art von
Wirtschaft sicher man passte sich an den
Mangel an Ressourcen an aber das führte
auch zu einer neuen Art zu denken und
das Leben anzugehen
wir versuchen die Arten von Nutzpflanzen
die wir anbauen wollen zu
diversifizieren und auch mit Natur
Schutzprogrammen zusammenzuarbeiten
umarten und Lebensräume zu erhalten und
der Natur ihren Lauf zu lassen damit die
Arten zurückkehren die wir brauchen und
die die Nutzpflanzen brauchen um
produktiv zu sein
wir wollen kein Hurricane oder
Tropensturm sie sind schon vorbereitet
die Ernte ist im Gange sie wollen
weitermachen und fertig werden die
Menschen wollen wissen woher ihr Essen
kommt irgendwann wollen die Leute
vielleicht auch wissen wo ihr Banker
wohnt und wer ist und ob ich eine
Beziehung zu ihm habe wenn ich Geld
brauche um etwas zu reparieren kann ich
vielleicht jemanden finden der mir hilft
ich meine es geht nicht darum dass die
Regierung den Banken vorschreibt was sie
zu tun haben oder uns sagt was wir tun
können es gibt noch viele Möglichkeiten
wir sollten kleinere Banken haben sie
aufspalten damit sie nicht zu groß zum
Scheitern werden wenn sie Fehler machen
sollten Sie scheitern ohne eine totale
Systemkrise auszulösen und was
wahrscheinlich auch getan werden muss
ist die Einführung von Regeln die es dem
Finanzsektor unmöglich machen innerhalb
des Finanzsektors selbst so viele
zusätzliche Schulden zu machen
wir müssen diese Unvollkommenheit des
Marktes irgendwie korrigieren wenn Sie
einen privat haben wollen wenn Sie Ihr
Risiko absichern wollen gut aber sie
müssen dem zugrunde liegenden
Vermögenswert ausgesetzt sein
ich erinnere mich dass ich nach einer
großen Überschwemmung in Florida
Fernseher und sie Interviewten diesen
Mann und er sagte mein Vater hat zweimal
wieder aufgebaut mein Großvater hat
zweimal wieder aufgebaut und ich werde
es wieder tun und der Reporter drehte
sich der Kamera und sagte das ist der
amerikanische weg ich dachte der
Reporter sollte sagen das ist dumm man
kann das nicht immer wieder machen das
ist die Definition von Irrsinn
es ist im Grunde das Vertrauen in die
Geldverwaltung und das Vertrauen in die
zukünftige Produktivität eines Landes
das uns Vertrauen in die Währung gibt
und nicht die Vorstellung dass die
Zentralbank ein paar Goldbarren
versteckt
es gibt einen Punkt des Widerstands an
dem die Regierungen keinen Zugang zu
Kapital haben um das Problem zu lösen
[Musik]
die Befürchtung ist wenn wir das System
nicht mehr retten können dann stürzen
wir ab mit riesigen Nebenwirkungen die
Hoffnung und das klingt ein bisschen
zynisch aber die Hoffnung ist dass wir
unser System wahrscheinlich erst nach
einem Crash neu ordnen können ich glaube
die Geschichte der Menschheit zeigt dass
wir die Art und Weise wie wir leben und
uns organisieren ohne einen solchen
Crash nicht wirklich grundlegend
verändern können niemand will das und
ich bin die letzte die das will wenn ich
an die 30er Jahre denke und ich bin
Deutsche wenn man überlegt welche
Auswirkungen eine Krise haben kann
wissen wir einfach nicht wie wir am
anderen Ende des Tunnels wieder
herauskommen werden ohne diese Krise
sehe ich einfach nicht genug politischen
Einfluss um die Art wie wir unser
Finanzsystem organisieren grundlegend zu
ändern
wenn der Klimawandel eintritt wird es
echte Probleme geben und es wird echte
wie Sie sagten echte Knappheiten geben
und es werden echte Migranten kommen und
es wird und dann werden wir wirklich
pleite sein weil es nach dem
Zusammenbruch der umgekehrten Pyramide
sein wird und dann ist es so als würden
wir Somalia bitten den Klimawandel zu
bekämpfen
deine Kritik ist also dass wir uns der
Realität nicht stellen und uns nicht
anpassen das stimmt meine Antwort darauf
ist dass ich immer noch an die
Demokratie glaube ich glaube dass wir es
als Volk schaffen können als
Gesellschaft und ich glaube wir können
die Institutionen der USA die diesem
Land über 200 Jahre lang sehr gut
gedient haben nehmen und ins 21
Jahrhundert führen und die Menschheit
voranbringen das ist eine Glaubensfrage
aber es ist der Glaube der zum Handeln
motiviert
wir haben fast alle Werkzeuge alle
finanziellen Ressourcen und
Institutionen die dieses Problem lösen
können es ist die Art von
Herausforderung die die Menschheit auf
eine Weise zusammenbringen könnte wie
sie noch nie zuvor zusammengebracht
wurde
ich wünschte es gäbe mehr Gespräche mehr
Leute auf beiden Seiten die miteinander
reden denn jeder von dem wir denken dass
er auf der Gegenseite ist ist genauso
recht schaffen wir sollten
zusammenkommen um zu sehen wenn man sich
mit solchen Leuten trifft stellt man
fest dass die Meinungsverschiedenheiten
eigentlich ziemlich klein sind ja das
meine ich die meisten Leute sind sich zu
95% einig aber es gibt Kräfte die diese
Meinungsverschiedenheiten verschärfen
und populär machen wollen
das ist eine Frage der menschlichen
Natur was verkauft sich also sag mir was
verkauft sich worauf wartest du wenn es
um dich herum passiert man muss Leute
finden die pflegt Konflikt Konflikt das
ist es diese Art von Dialog zwischen
Vater und Sohn zu schaffen wissen sie
das ist mein Kind und so sie müssen ja
einige wilde Unterhaltungen führen
komplett anderer Meinung des
Kapitalismus
[Musik]